moment of the sexual experience will ask
the young lady who's your daddy this
should be remixed if officer akimov is
watching
this could be the next remix masterpiece
dude because just wait till you see what
happens here oh officer officer akimov
is here uh that's beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
no i'm a christian
[Music]
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
[Music]
is the most successful pimp on planet
earth to reverence the word of god to
trust it to preach it to teach it
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
george bush and george bush jr have been
penetrated by at least 100 men in their
anus a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand strong i didn't do it that's
not my problem oh i got down on my knees
[Music]
and tons and tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
let me say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done except they've
done it we've seen them
that certainly seems to be a story that
has been missed
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
pac-man's a loser pac-man's a loser
pac-man's a loser
like that
look at that
alex jones is lying to you that might
come as a shock man
[Music]
jones has fake callers jones has fake
callers
[Music]
arrest tyranny
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the
toilet is this the explanation is this
the explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
mangoes my bags are mangoes
[Music]
i love mangoes too
okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime my bag of mangoes now costs 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal
that's it
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
welcome everybody what a day what a day
given the circumstances i do have a
cappuccino here we are joining cpac this
is the candice blowin owens um uh blow
blow hard no the candace oh you know who
it is
um panel
and it's gonna be completely weaponized
and delusional
um in 30 minutes president joe biden is
going to announce his supreme court pick
which is going to be incredible and
historic moment we then have a gensake
white house press briefing and then
later we are going to hear from governor
christie gnome and ben carson it's a
crazy crazy day
um
and uh i guess let's just join cpac in
progress so settle in everybody we're
gonna have a lot to go over here um i
have grown and i have changed in so many
ways and so many of you guys in this
room have been with me on this journey
some of you guys met me as an on campus
some of us even remember when you were a
democrat before it became profitable for
you to claim to be on the right
definitely all of you know me as a
public speaker and i would imagine that
a lot of you guys found me through my
personal organization blexit which you
know aims to bring many of us actually
find you repulsive
[Music]
and
some of our more obtuse friends in media
uh seem to know me as a black white
supremacist
not sure how they uh worked out that
piece of brilliance
but today is the first time that i
emerge on the cpac stage within my most
official and my most accomplished
capacity your most weaponized stage as a
mother
not just one at home but also we've got
one on the way
and thank you
and i can say that this time um as i
stand on this stage i have never been
more certain about who i am and what my
purpose is in this world
so on the topic of motherhood i wanted
to tell you guys something that i
learned about five years ago which
really shocked me ready so in the wild
far from the flowery depictions that you
see of peta where the animals are loving
each other and hugging all the time and
the only thing that happens bad in the
wild happens because of awful human
beings
in the wild male bears
actually kill their cubs
so the reason that hunter bear bears
hunters will seek out male bears and
hunt them is because they're trying to
preserve
the bear population in certain areas and
let me explain that because it's a weird
thing to sometimes bears kill their cubs
but obviously if bears killed every cub
there'd be no bears they're also
committing cannibalism sometimes they
actually will eat
their cubs so the question is why
well similar to the human species when
female bears give birth and are nursing
their cubs they cannot go into heat
but and this is what the papa bears have
worked out if a nursing mother loses her
cubs the lactation will stop and she
will want you to be shocked but this is
actually this she's actually leading up
to something about ukraine it's just
it's meandering cubs for
sex really is what it comes down to
right savage to say the least
but there's something else that i'm
getting at and there is something that
is amazing tell us what it is because i
can't see what i learned and it's that
when the male bear does attack the mama
bear fights back with everything in her
to protect her offspring and most times
that is a fight to the death that is
actually where the true concept of the
mama bear which we all use colloquially
today it comes from that concept of them
fighting to the death for their cubs and
as a result those of you who live near
wildlife will know this
when when you see a bear cub anywhere no
matter how cute and cuddly it looks you
do not go near it right
because you know somewhere nearby
mama bear is lurking and she will take
no prisoners
now i share this with you because
lately i've been left wondering
what our human world might look like
if we all drew inspiration from such a
notion a world where even seeing a child
signaled a respectable threat and a
retreat from would-be predators
to the school boards she's talking like
you would to a a room of first graders
but i guess it's mostly adults who are
there um okay once the panel starts
we'll get back to it i'm finding this
particular speech completely
cringe-worthy
um
mikey says in the bible bears also
killed children for mocking a prophet's
big ears i'm not sure i know what that
means
uh there we name may never get to the
point i want to say thank you to hammer
worfer as well as frank milk bobby and a
pet giraffe for the twitch prime
subscriptions appreciate it guys we've
been streaming every single day and it's
so great to have you here also want to
say thanks to david west who just
grabbed a membership on my website and
is number five today because cpac is
going on you can use the coupon code
cpac
trash
to get a discount and first person to
use the code cpac trash today i'll send
you a free item from my online store now
it is not there's something for everyone
today we're going to have the weaponized
delusions of candace owens in a soon to
start panel
at the top of the hour joe biden has
decided who will be
the next supreme court justice it is
judge jackson and he will be introducing
her she will be speaking at the top of
the hour it's going to be a great event
and i look forward to covering it
next hour
white house secretary press secretary
jenn saki will be doing another press
briefing and we are continuing to
monitor the situation in ukraine and
russia uh we have some video from on the
ground we are monitoring also um uh the
the view in kiev and a whole bunch of
different things i i have so many
different things to talk about with you
guys so i'm really glad that you're here
one quick note i want to send a very
extra double special thank you
to our viewers on tv
we have had uh the best four day period
as you can see here on twitch that we've
had in months twitch has been really
stagnant
sort of like uh you know one of those
standing pools of water filled with
mosquitoes and
it gets clogged as you know and it just
it hasn't been good things are flowing a
little more freely now on twitch and
we've got had a very very nice uh four
day streak on twitch of growing our
following there so i really appreciate
that and want to thank everybody who's
been watching on twitch as a programming
reminder we will be here for a few hours
covering all of these different things
today tomorrow i will be back with you
at 6 00 pm eastern for donald trump's
keynote at cpac um i'm expecting it to
be extremely corrosive and and filled
with disinformation
that'll be 6 p.m eastern tomorrow and
then tuesday i hope nobody will miss joe
biden's state of the union address where
there may be major statements made about
covid there may be major statements made
about russia ukraine inflation supply
chain gas prices new initiatives a lot
of different things it's seeming to me
like one of the most consequential um
state of the union addresses in a very
long time so that will be
tuesday eight eastern the speech starts
at nine
we will start at eight eastern on
tuesday few other super chats coming in
where are the republicans slamming biden
about markets being down guys i am uh
i have to tell you
i am almost giddy at the numbers today
look at this beautiful dow
up
850 points we still have over two hours
to go it has been so disastrous lately
five day is down
the one month is down six month is down
year to date is down one year still up i
am i have to tell you i am thrilled and
i never i just keep buying as you all
know my strategy i just keep bye bye bye
we have a beautiful day today on the dow
and in the markets and i'm very very
glad to see that uh i don't make any
decisions day to day i just keep buying
that's all it is
david sir thank you for your coverage
can you explain the crazy hair oh i was
out snow blowing and i was wearing a hat
and it was snow and it's all crazy great
hair david listen to king gizzard and
the lizard wizard and keep up the good
work okay very good we will uh we will
look at that now i saw something here
e hold on a second bbc eu freezing
putin's assets oh that would be just
delightful
is that true
the bbc is reporting that now putin's
personal assets will be frozen
let me see i'm not seeing that come
across the wires yet
bbc putin assets
frozen let's see
not seeing anything on that
right now
let's see
bbc has confirmed eu will enact asset
freed of putin oh that is beautiful i
absolutely love they're gonna freeze
putin's assets that's great we'll get to
that a little bit later um let's let's
stick with this uh for now i do wanna
say thank you to chris collins chris is
the first person today to use the coupon
code cpac trash chris please email info
davidpakman.com to get your free item
also welcome to mina sposito
and rowan bro
both of whom also use today's coupon
code cpac trash let's just jump right in
in the library
uh at a school in virginia
can you talk to us about that story a
bit
well yeah that was my son's high school
i'm a stay-at-home mom as you mentioned
the importance of being a stay-at-home
mom right and radical radical
homeschooling guys it's the way to
indoctrinate radical homeschooling
system and for uh foreign private school
and i had seen a couple of stories on
the news about some uh parents taking
these pornographic books that they had
found in their children's you know
coming home in their backpacks or
whatever and i like the bible is that a
thing now is that something i should be
worried about and should i be looking at
what's going on at the high school and i
looked the books up and they were there
and so i took them to my school board
meeting and i showed the images and i
read them out loud to my school board
and um i took the books and i said cut
it out not like that the books were
there or did they not like that you had
discovered that the books were there
um
they didn't care that the books were
there they didn't like that i brought it
to the public's attention and uh they
didn't like that you were making a big
deal out of books you need to do that as
a parent because i'm a christian right
um
right
this is something that you know this
shouldn't be going on in our schools we
actually have obscenity laws in this
this being what reading
and you cannot present this type of
material to children it's actually
listed on the american bar association's
website as grooming you cannot show
sexual images to children under the
guise of even education so
that's meant to apply to very specific
situations not to classroom lessons in
front of a group of 20 kids that that's
the dumbest thing i've maybe ever heard
on this issue ted
um
you represent north carolina is that
district 15 is that correct
13 13 is my lucky number i i want to ask
you a question because we're seeing so
many parents that are concerned and
showing up the school board meetings the
school board meetings are angry that
parents are asking questions and it's
very clear that we've seeded control to
them
particularly when it comes to covid
there was a lot of concern we know the
science is in
children are not at risk more at risk
certainly than the adults who are
allowed to roam around freely without a
mask in society
what's going on at the government level
well what we're seeing is more
engagement than ever from parents uh we
you know
pretty much school boards for a long
time people were not engaged they would
look to their federal races the state
senate the u.s senate the state house
now we've got people showing up to
school boards and throwing tantrums like
their children it's a great great thing
we've got going huh they're school
boards so this is fantastic but from the
u.s house i mean we're seeing
legislation that recognizes as
conservatives that we're seeing more uh
psychological damage to these children
uh we're seeing more you know what's
damaging to kids seeing mom on the news
throwing a temper tantrum in front of
all your teachers and down we're seeing
a 25 increase
of children that are 5 to 11
that are that are causing self-harm and
having clinical depression this is very
very wrong i mean it's destructive to
our children we don't know how long this
is going to last so we've got bills that
we're supporting from representative
marker
mark green from dan bishop and from
others that say let's take these masks
off let's not fund these schools that
are keeping kids home and not not
allowing them back into the classroom so
look we we've got a lot of things but we
got to win we got to get back to the
majority and we got to take that gavel
back from nancy pelosi absolutely
it's funny how he's like it's really all
about school boards it's not about
national politics anymore but what we
really have to do to fix this is like
take the speakership back from pelosi i
thought you just said it didn't matter
anymore magical damage
you have used your platform to really
speak out particularly about women's
issues and this battle that we're seeing
uh the trans agenda in the classroom
trying to teach children to pick their
genders uh talk about what is actually
happening and why it's so important
they want you to believe that someone's
going
kids
today you're going to pick
do you want to be a boy
or do you want to be a girl today
everybody will sign up for one or the
other
give me a break guys
uh he sent out an order to all public
schools stating that if a teacher or
student says that there's two genders
that they're guilty of harassment today
everybody picks a desk tomorrow
everybody picks a gender discipline so i
went at it with him
and asked him how many genders are there
he tried to
deflect from my question and i went
after him and he finally said to me i
won't answer your question
so you know they're openly hostile to
our american values and it it's you know
it's time is transphobia an american
value i guess to these people it is than
ever now that regular people like
like me a grandma um parents truck
drivers pilots you know they're very
hostile but if you mess with our kids
you're gonna see hostility i mean in a
new way
and i'll toss this to both of you guys
uh since you're working in government it
seems like it's worse than hostility to
me this seems like active child abuse
right when you're purposefully teaching
children the role so let me interject
here i mean it's like this this is all
pablum and it's just worthless trash
one of the really important takeaways we
need to get from this is
as dumb as these people are as
non-issues as these topics are
as
ignorant as everything going on is
they are so better organized than we are
they are all there they've paid to be
there they're listening they're taking
direction they're getting behind these
issues they're terrible issues to get
behind but they are so much more
organized than we are and they fund this
stuff they they pay and kids go down to
this you know teenagers college kids
they go down
they invest in this and this is why the
country keeps moving left you ask people
what's your view on abortion the
countries has left as ever you ask
people what's your view on some basic
level of health care for everybody the
countries is left as ever
and yet they keep winning partially
because of gerrymandering but partially
because they are so much better
organized they're going to leave this
inspired and ready to go all to do all
this stuff at the school board meetings
in all these different places and they
are a team that to some degree is
functioning there's a bit of a civil war
the pro-trump anti-trump thing
and we'll that's sort of separate and
we'll talk about that tomorrow
but we should laugh off the substance
but the fact that this is going on and
that they're so engaged this is
partially why they're winning this is
partially why they're winning the left
doesn't do this stuff real time
to today
yeah candace thank you for the question
i grew up in los angeles california i
live in new york city but i spent the
first 18 years of my life in los angeles
i went to sixth avenue elementary school
which is probably about 90 95 black
as you said in the 60s and 70s that
general era and uh we used to start
class with the pledge of allegiance
we learned our history we learned that
george washington was a good man who
founded our country uh abraham lincoln
emancipated the slaves um
it was a great country we're proud of it
and we we celebrated things like oh
fourth of july is coming isn't that
great we before we had president's day
we had george washington's birthday and
abraham lincoln's birthday which we
celebrated and uh in this 90-95 black
school we uh did things like
learn how good the country is we
actually had lessons where we learned
how to write we learned how to do math
we didn't hear spending time talking
about gender that you know that didn't
come up until sex ed and junior high or
high school and the stuff that's going
on now that i hear about is just some
completely uh alien it seems like it's
dropped out of another planet and um
now kids spend a lot of time learning
how to
hate themselves hate people of other
races we'll talk about critical race
theory in a bit and it's a totally
different agenda and it doesn't seem to
be about learning skills you can succeed
as an american citizen but learning how
to hate your country and i heard the
word child abuse i described the current
government school system as a system of
institutionalized child abuse and i
think that's charitable to put it that
way
and on the topic of race i i always say
that it's unbelievable people huh
progressive and it's become regressive
right so they said oh we've got to break
away from uh black americans being
systematically deemed underprivileged so
what we're going to do now is we've gone
so forward we're going to tell them that
systematically they're underprivileged
and that white people will forever be
i'm feeling a bit nauseous from this so
we're going to move over to a better
event we are going to move over to the
announcement that judge katanji brown
jackson is president joe biden's nominee
to become the 116th associate justice of
the u.s supreme court the first black
woman who would be on the court if
confirmed
and
we'll get back to
cpac okay so don't uh there's gonna be a
bit of something for everybody oh i did
have some clips here so let's go to that
hold on i have so many different clips
to play for you here is the ukrainian
president zelensky posting a video of
himself with his team
he is in the government corridor in kiev
he has not left he is there and he is
attempting to defend
defend ukraine take a look
okay so they are there okay he has not
left he is he is he is there
um air raid sirens ringing out in kiev
just hours ago
[Music]
[Applause]
a little bit of chicken drop
what the hell how did it all of a sudden
go into applebee's that's crazy okay i
only meant to play the uh i only meant
to play the airaid siren
um
okay here is the same president of
ukraine zolensky saying listen
uh you can come here and help us defend
ukraine
politics
they need help
they need help guys it is it is a crazy
crazy situation that is going on there
as we stand by here for the announcement
of judge katanji brown jackson as the
next nominee to the supreme court uh i
guess because we have more of a sense of
what is in ukraine rather than what
might be
the stock market has had a little bit of
a pop today the dow up nearly 800 points
right now
recovering just a fraction of what has
been lost over the last uh
five to thirty days
um but certainly significant instability
there
um
jd says how much you wanna bet these
people haven't picked up a bio textbook
in the last 30 years oh yeah the people
in this room don't read books that's
crazy no no no i mean the vast majority
literally what they know is what people
like the people on the stage tell them
that's it
that's it and it's very very dangerous
for sure
thank you to michael stone and patty
mcninja also thanks to jen here for
gifting two subscriptions via twitch
putting us at 12. i want to tell you
guys that listen as a general thing
i would love for you to sign up on my
website and support what we're doing
we're under particular attack right now
from what i'm calling the alt left or
the tool sees here's one such message
from robert robert roden yesterday and
said david i have unsubscribed from your
show
because you revealed your r tribal
saying specifically
tulsi gabbard speaks to citizens of all
labels
calling us to remember our common ground
is far greater than our pet peeves so
they did not like my critique of tulsi
they have pulled their financial support
and you know what that's fine
that's absolutely fine go go but
what i'm asking you is help us fight
these people really help us fight these
people you can sign up at joinpakman.com
we have this coupon code cpac trash
which you can use for a discount if you
prefer
a ukraine related discount code you can
use the code please don't war
and then if you just want an old school
code you can use the code obama obama
exactly so that is something we are up
against and we are up against it
very very strongly right now
uh what else do we have
chris says is it ableism to say the
right is crazy kids in school that can't
listen learn and grow are considered to
have a learning disability right
yeah we we get into a semantic
discussion about whether like whether
when we say these people are nuts are we
saying literally mental illness
or are we saying just basically like uh
it it's cult like deliberate ignorance
and i mean it's an argument to be had
and you know i think everybody in my
audience understands i'm i'm not i'm not
stigmatizing actual mental illness when
i talk in these terms
bay photo says sir this new super chat
system is
something bad a lot of chats get missed
i enjoy supporting the channel with
super chats but it's getting frustrating
i have no control over how youtube
functions unfortunately i wish i could
control
everything about how youtube works but
youtube made a change to the live
streaming algorithm and the best system
we have is one where as the super chats
come in they pop in up here next to
where it says 4.99 and then i click on
them to build them up
how to bring them up and if they're two
dollars under two dollars they just
don't even pop up okay so here's another
one you say it's a non-issue but a local
high school is offering the course
hating your country 101 okay i don't
know if that's a i don't know if that's
a joke i just have no idea i've never
heard of that course
that's all that's all i can tell you
um any moment we will be hearing from
president joe biden and oh here we go
this is a very very major moment guys
this will be the first nomination of a
black woman to the supreme court
good
afternoon today uh
as we watch freedom and liberty under
attack abroad
i'm here to fulfill my responsibilities
under the constitution
to preserve freedom and liberty right
here in the united states of america
and it's my honor to introduce to the
country
a daughter of former public school
teachers
a proven consensus builder
an accomplished lawyer
a distinguished jurist one of the
nation's most on one of the nation's
most prestigious courts
my nominee for the united states supreme
court is judge catan g jackson
you know uh four weeks ago when
a member of the court a friend of mine
who used to work together in the senate
justice stephen breyer announced his
retirement
i said then choosing someone to serve on
the united states supreme court is one
of the most serious
constitutional responsibility a
president has true and i mean it
i promised the process would be rigorous
that i would select a nominee worthy of
justice briar's legacy of excellence and
decency not a joke someone extremely
qualified with a brilliant legal mind
with the utmost character and integrity
which equally is important
and though i would bring
this decision
to this decision my perspective as a
lawyer
former constitutional law professor
chairman of the judiciary committee for
many many years
and i'm almost reluctant to say it
someone who's been presided over more
supreme court nominations than almost
anyone
living today which makes me 28 years old
you know i started doing it when i was
32. that's a bunch of molecules devoted
much of my career to thinking about the
constitution and the role of the supreme
court
with that perspective
i carefully stuttered the right study
the record of candidates i've invited
senators of both political parties to
offer their ideas and points of view and
i've met with a number of them
as a result
because i i truly respect not only the
consent i know they give consent but it
said that the constitution says advice
and consent
and i sought the advice of democrats and
republicans
i've consulted with leading
legal scholars and lawyers
and i've been fortunate to have the
advice of the vice president harris i
mean sincerely
an exceptional lawyer a former attorney
general in california and a former
member of the senate judiciary committee
and during this process we look for
someone who like justice breyer has a
pragmatic understanding that the law
must work for the american people
someone who has historical perspective
to understand that the constitution
is a resilient charter of liberty
someone with the wisdom to appreciate
that the constitution protects certain
inalienable rights
rights that fall within the most
fundamental personal freedoms
that our society recognizes
in the end someone with extraordinary
character
will bring to the supreme court an
independent mind
uncompromising integrity and with a
strong moral compass and the courage to
stand up for what she thinks is right
for too long
our government our courts haven't looked
like america
and i believe it's time that we have a
court reflects the full talents and
greatness of our nation with a nominee
of extraordinary qualifications
and that we inspire all young people to
believe that they can one day
serve their country at the highest level
i've admired these traits of pragmatism
historical perspective wisdom character
and
the jurors nominated by republican
presidents as well as democratic
presidents
and today
i'm pleased to introduce to the american
people a candidate who continues in this
great tradition
judge jackson grew up in miami florida
and by the way the mayor of miami
republican endorsed you
i thought that was interesting
parents grew up with segregation but
never gave up hope
that their children would enjoy the true
promise of america
her parents graduated from historic
black colleges and became public school
teachers
her mom a principal her dad a teacher
who later went back to school and became
a lawyer representing that very school
district that school board
judge jackson describes finding her love
for the law
from an apartment complex at the
university of miami where her dad was
attending law school
she'd draw in her coloring book at the
dining room table next to her dad's law
books
she grew up to be a star student
elected mayor of her junior high school
and president of her high school class
where she was a standout she was a
standout on the speech and debate team
and it was after a debate tournament
that took place at harvard when she was
in high school
that she believed she could one day be a
student there
there were those who told her she
shouldn't set her sights too high
but she refused to accept limits
others said for her
she had gone to harvard undergraduate
school where she graduated magnum [ __ ]
laude
she went into attendance
i like that top student and editor of
the prestigious law review
then
she applied for highly competitive and
coveted clerkship on the united states
supreme court and she was selected
the justice who thought she was worthy
of this high honor was a young lawyer
was none other than justice stephen
breyer
whose seat i'm nominating her to fill
not only did she learn
about being a judge from justice breyer
himself
she saw the great rigor through which
justice breyer approached his work
she learned from his willingness to work
with colleagues with different
viewpoints
critical qualities for in my view for
any supreme court justice
now years later
she steps up to fill justice breyer's
place in the court with a uniquely
accomplished and wide-ranging background
she served both in public service
as a federal public defender a federal
public defender and a private law
practice
as an accomplished lawyer and pursuing
with a prestigious law firm
if confirmed
she will join justice sotomayor
as the only other member of the united
states supreme court who has experience
as a trial court judge
a critical qualification in my view
and once again
following the footsteps of her mentor
justice breyer she'd become the only
member of the court who previously
served as a member of the united states
sentencing commission
and she brings additional perspective to
the court as well she comes from a
family of law enforcement
with her brother and uncles having
served as police officers
that's one reason i expect by the
fraternal order of police
the national organization today said and
i quote there's little doubt she's has
the temperament the intellect and legal
experience and family background have
earned disappointment
and they went on to say
they're confident she will quote
approach her future cases with an open
mind and treat issues related to law
enforcement fairly and justly
incredibly
judge jackson has already been confirmed
by the united states senate three times
first to serve on the u.s sentencing
commission
a bipartisan independent commission we
helped design to reduce the unwarranted
disparities in sentencing
and promote transparency and fairness in
the criminal justice system
on the commission
judge jackson was known for working with
democrats and republicans to find common
ground on critical issues second
she was concerned but confirmed by the
united states senate with bipartisan
support
on the federal district court to
administer justice with the special
rigors and fairness that come with
presiding over trials
and third
she was confirmed with bipartisan senate
vote to serve on the u.s court of
appeals for the district of columbia
considered the second most powerful
court behind the supreme court itself
and the courts she once argued cases
before as a distinguished advocate
and when judge jackson was nominated to
the circuit court
one of his distinguished retired members
judge thomas griffin
a former general counsel of brigham
young university a lot of speculation in
the chat about whether she'll get
confirmed i think there's no question
that she'll get confirmed yes there will
be republicans who vote against her but
she is obviously qualified and there is
no
you you're you're going to have
republicans who vote to confirm and
she's going to get confirmed assuming
there's no huge mess up like
you know waiting uh some period of time
so that mcconnell can try to delay it or
whatever there's another superb
qualification
for service on the supreme court
three of her of the current supreme
court justices also served as the d.c
circuit judges when john jackson's now
serves
her opinions are always carefully
reasoned
tethered to precedent and demonstrate
reflect respect for how the law impacts
everyday people
it doesn't mean she puts her thumb on
the scale of justice one way or the
other
but she understands the broader impact
of her decisions
whether it's cases addressing the rights
of workers or government service
she cares about making sure that a
democracy works for the american people
she listens
she looks people in the eye lawyers
defendants victims and families
and she strives to ensure that everyone
understands why she made a decision
what the law is and what it means to
them
she strives to be fair
to get it right to do justice
that's something all of us should
remember
and it's something i've thought about
throughout this process
as a matter of fact i thought about it
walking over here with her
one floor below
we have several displays celebrating
black history month
one of them
includes the judicial oath of office
taken and signed by
justice thurgood marshall himself
an oath that will be once again
administered to a distinguished american
who will help write the next chapter in
the history of the journey of america
a journey that judge jackson will take
with her family
i hope i don't embarrass him but her
husband patrick i'm a surgeon doctor
patrick stand up let him see who you are
there you go surgeon patrick dot our
undergraduate students at harvard and
he's this distinguished cancer surgeon
at georgetown
and like so many women in this country
judge jackson is a working mom
she had her eldest child
natalya when she was a private lawyer in
practice she had her second child laila
when she served as us on the u.s
sentencing commission stand up leo
i asked layla when i showed her through
the office whether she'd like to be
president she's like
there's other things
anyway layla you're welcome to be here
thank you so much
and welcome
your sister who's up in school in rhode
island now
i have children and grandchildren let me
tell you judge
you're always a mom
that's not going to change no matter
what you're doing
you're on whether you're on the supreme
court or not
and i've always had a deep respect for
the supreme court judiciary as a
co-equal branch of the government i mean
it
the court is equally as important as the
presidency or the congress it's co-equal
so today
i'm pleased to nominate judge jackson
who will bring extraordinary
qualifications
deep experience and intellect and a
rigorous judicial record to the court
judge jackson deserves to be confirmed
as the next justice of the supreme court
i've met with the chairman and ranking
members of the senate judiciary
committee
senator dick durbin
senator chuck grassley and my hope is
that they will move promptly and i know
they'll move fairly we'll cover those
hearings jackson congratulations
and the podium is yours let me pull this
out for you
there you go
you got it
okay what's biden doing say presents
can't do much
thank you thank you
thank you
oh whoa whoa whoa i see
oh i love the step stool that's the best
that is the best
thank you very much mr president i am
truly humbled by the extraordinary honor
of this nomination
and i am especially grateful for the
care that you have taken in discharging
your constitutional duty in service of
our democracy with all that is going on
in the world today
i also offer my sincere
thanks to you as well madam vice
president
for your invaluable role
in this nomination process
i must begin these very brief remarks by
thanking god
for delivering me
to this point in my professional journey
republicans should like that has been
blessed beyond measure
and i do know
that one can only come this far
by faith
wow among my many blessings and indeed
the very first is the fact that i was
born in this great country
guys it doesn't sound like she hates
america hope and democracy the world has
ever known
i was also blessed from my early days to
have had a supportive and loving family
my mother and father
who have been married for 54 years are
at their home in florida right now and i
know that they could not be more proud
it was my father who started me on this
path
when i was a child as
the president mentioned
my father made the fateful decision to
trans uh to transition
from his job as a public high school
history teacher and go to law school
some of my earliest memories are of him
sitting at the kitchen table reading his
law books
i watched him study
and he became my first professional okay
do you guys want to stay here or go to
governor christie gnome at cpac i did
invaluable support in those early days
working full-time
to enable my father's career transition
while also guiding and inspiring
four-year-old me
okay most everybody's saying stay fair
my brother kitaj
came along half a decade later
and i'm so proud of all that he's
accomplished
after graduating from howard university
he became a police officer and a
detective on some of the toughest
streets in the inner city of baltimore
after that he enlisted
in the army
serving two tours of duty in the middle
east
i believe that he was following the
example set by my uncles who are in law
enforcement
you may have read
that i have one uncle who got caught up
in the drug trade and received a life
sentence that is true um
but law enforcement also runs in my
family in addition to my brother i had
two uncles who served decades as you
guys think republicans will grill her
about an uncle who who was in the drug
trade do you guys think that'll come up
in the confirmation hearings like
they'll try to assail her character over
that by the grace of god as testament to
the love and support that i've received
from my family
i have also been blessed with many dear
friends colleagues mentors law clerks
i could not possibly name all of the
people to whom i owe great thanks
but i must mention specifically the
three brilliant jurists
for whom i had the privilege of serving
as a law clerk at the outset of my legal
career
u.s district judge patty sarris in
massachusetts
u.s court of appeals bruce judge bruce
celia in rhode island
and last but certainly not least
associate justice stephen breyer of the
supreme court of the united states i
mean listen brett kavanaugh was uh was
cheered and lionized for things he
allegedly did
but she'll be attacked for things her
uncle did yeah i know guys i understand
the hypocrisy
that a supreme court justice can perform
at the highest level of skill and
integrity while also being guided by
civility
grace
pragmatism
and generosity of spirit
justice breyer
the members of the senate will decide if
i fill your seat
but please know that i could never
fill your shoes wow
to my dear family
those who are here with me now and those
who are watching from home i am forever
indebted to you for your love and
support
to my beloved husband patrick
thank you for being my rock today and
every day for these past 26 years i love
you
to my daughters talia and laila you are
the light of my life
please know
that whatever title i may hold or
whatever job i may have
i will still be your mom
that will never change
there are so many other people i would
love to be able to address and to thank
but
time is short so let me end
by sharing an interesting coincidence
that has actually meant a great deal to
me
over the years
as it happens
i share a birthday
with the first black woman ever to be
appointed as a federal judge
the honorable constance baker motley wow
we were born exactly 49 years to the day
apart
today i proudly stand on judge motley's
shoulders
sharing not only her birthday
but also her steadfast and courageous
commitment to equal justice under law
wow
judge motley's life and career has been
a true inspiration to me
as i have pursued this professional path
and if i am fortunate enough to be
confirmed as the next associates justice
of the supreme court of the united
states
i can only hope that my life and career
my love of this country and the
constitution
and my commitment to upholding the rule
of law and the sacred principles upon
which this great nation was founded
will inspire future generations
of americans
thank you again mr president for this
extraordinary honor
i am really looking forward to her
schooling some senators during i forgot
to introduce the first lady dr jill
biden and the second gentleman i said
seems strange to say that but the second
doug is emer they're both here as well
so thank you okay good thank you
all right i look forward to her
schooling some senators on the law
that's going to be a great thing so an
historic day there for sure let's go now
to christy gnome develop delivering a
febrile screed rife with misinformation
at cpac reason law
and representative government
and in philadelphia in 1787
they put all of that together
in to craft the constitution of the
united states of america oh and before
we even do this
i have a very very
very important announcement i have just
learned that our good friend farron
cousins and our good friend mike pap
antonio
have pulled their show from russian
propaganda state television
here's farren
after a lengthy discussion this morning
mike papp antonio and i made the
decision to remove america's lawyer from
rt
we are immensely proud of the stories
we've covered and relationships we've
made but we are moving forward on our
own
and i congratulated them calling it
david pakman calling it an absolutely
perfect decision to be applauded and
congratulated
you guys all know i know these guys
really well
and i think this is a this is a
fantastic decision for them and they
started doing that show on rt a long
time ago when circumstances were
different it was always russian state tv
um and this is an absolutely perfect
decision
go to farren and say we are here with
peace and love from the david pakman
stream
and we support your decision we support
your decision because it is the right
decision it is the right decision
i do want to say a couple thank yous
mendo scholar one time for yo mind have
just signed up via twitch prime and her
numbers 13 and 14 also before we get
back to christy gnome
thanks to jeffett santana who just
signed up on my website with the code
obama
and thank you to samantha archibald
archibald who just signed up on my
website with the code obama
today is a great day to get a membership
fight the tulsi people who as you can
see here are unsubscribing they're
canceling me
bye bye
bye bye but a great day
for you to sign up at joinpakman.com
also thanks to humble hazard for the
twitch prime subscription let's get back
to christy gnome because of something
you said on facebook it's already
happening in the world and i'm not
talking about communist china's social
credit system i'm talking about justin
trudeau the canadian prime minister and
the emergencies act he passed yeah
which he has since rescinded i would be
interested if she should mention and has
rescinded it's on trucks he used
anti-terrorism finance laws to cover
crowdfunding platforms like give send go
and this is why the founders gave us the
constitution in the first place yes they
knew human nature had to attack justin
trudeau power
in 2020 when most states were shutting
down their economies and they were
forcing unconstitutional lockdowns we
did something very different in south
dakota we did nothing our state motto is
under god the people rule
and i followed it
is she dressed like david miscavige the
scientology guy is there something there
about that
as governor i believe that the best way
to fight a danger in our country was
through an informed and free american
people who made decisions for themselves
i refused to use unconstitutional powers
right we never issued mask mandates we
didn't mandate vaccines
we never kept anybody from going to
church and we kept kids in the classroom
look at this crowd huh
standing ovation for ignoring covid what
what what a world we live in
i didn't arrest or ticket or find a
single individual for exercising their
basic rights south dakota was the only
state that didn't even define what an
essential business was right every
business is essential
looking around
the world today we see fundamental
freedoms evaporating because of covid
lockdowns
not in south dakota we drew a clear line
and the line between tyranny and freedom
does anybody even know what she's
talking about i mean for months i walk
around i've been on the west coast the
east coast south and i'm everywhere
i sometimes see people wearing masks
like what what are they talking about
nobody knows crushes free speech
conservatives celebrate free expression
the left says america is racist and that
it's evil conservatives know america is
not the sum of our past mistakes
america's flawed flawed would be a
better word so-called experts is smart
enough to solve our problems but
conservatives know that everyone can
contribute and that experts are often
the last group who should be put in
charge
it's amazing what you can do when almost
no one lives in the state you're the
governor of
but he saved america at a crucial time
in our history boston there was
approximately 11 000 british soldiers
occupying the city during the
revolutionary war now george
washington's ragtag army of continentals
surrounded them but they were
outnumbered and outgunned the americans
carried only their personal muskets they
didn't have any cannons they didn't have
any ammunition
general washington knew that as soon as
the warmer weather would come they'd be
in trouble
now the british they were going to break
out of boston when it warmed up storm
his position and that they would end the
revolutionary war
but then a 25 year old bookseller named
henry knox came to general washington
with a proposal now knox had never been
in combat crowds dead they don't know
what's going on they're dazed here's
some interesting news i want to present
to you guys as christy gnome continues
ranting
um the former heavyweight boxing
champion vitali klitschko
uh
is currently the mayor of ukraine's
capital city kiev many people don't know
that and it's a shame that many people
don't know that
he is going to be staying in kiev and
taking up arms to fight the russian
invasion with his blood brother vladimir
klitschko
this is an incredible story an
incredible story
they plan to fight look at this partners
to
observe this strategy that is happening
nowadays in ukraine
and this
senseless war
which is not going to have any winners
but losers nope
i just want to
tell you we must stay united
no no beta energy here guys
against this aggression against russian
aggression
don't let it
happen continue happening in ukraine
don't let it happening in europe
and eventually in the
world united were strong
support ukraine thank you
wow so he's literally going to be taking
up arms and staying which is which is i
mean it what what is happening in
ukraine and russia right now is
it it's it's just an incredible thing
it's horrifying
um
and
i mean what
what can we even say you were writing a
chapter of that story too and what will
it say what should we do
first number one speak the truth
the left lives on lies
it's part of their power to frighten
people i love this super chat message
david sir enjoy this tranche of my
donation budget and if you're not
careful you may receive a more severe
tranche of donations in the future i
will be careful avi thank you let them
know that they are not alone in thinking
that remind them that there is a reality
and a truth still in this world we can
know it and we can live by it right sets
us free
and it makes us happy
right second never give up
we won unmasked mandates because people
got involved in their communities and we
are going to they didn't really win like
most places had mass mandates at the
height of the pandemic and just about
every place has gotten rid of them
and when we do it well because thousands
of ordinary people across our country
simply said
enough national politics starts on your
street it starts in your neighborhood
get involved lead
find the best fighter that you can and
have their back in the trenches
that's the beauty of federalism
remember what we are fighting to
conserve
when i served in congress
i'd often walk past the national
archives and there's an inscription on
the outside of the building
that says this the glory and romance
folks we have breaking news that it
appears as though russian forces are
pushing across ukraine weapons to people
who have military training and they are
even telling people to prepare molotov
cocktails if it's necessary and we're
also seeing that here in the south with
increased military activity around the
city where i am right now
richard the president there president
zielinski has offered to negotiate with
president putin what would be the
conditions for negotiations to happen
for zielinski none zielinski has said
time and time again that he wants to
meet with vladimir putin that he wants
to meet with him directly he wants to
meet with him with the united states he
wants to meet with him with any uh buddy
who will meet uh directly with putin
arrange a meeting between him and
vladimir putin uh but putin has not been
willing to take that direct meeting with
uh with zielinski a president he is
called a neo-nazi
and who's
who he clearly wants to unseat from
power uh when you hear putin i am
getting word that the keefe cam is down
i'm gonna keep looking very clear that
the goal of this entire operation is to
get rid of not just uh zielinski but the
entire system that that put him in
in power a democratic system that has
been in place here uh for the last eight
years so russia says its conditions are
simple
ukraine has to give up ukraine has to
stop okay so here we have a number of
different cameras of what's happening
and nothing in particular going on right
now
uh yeah he's saying he's willing to talk
now
at any time in any place and russia is
saying only after a surrender
the ukrainian military is still fighting
richard they're fighting an uh a
military
presence from russia that is
significantly larger and more powerful
but they don't really seem to know too
too much of what's going on we are over
at cpac what is expected next is
a very weaponized panel on making middle
east peace great again
and then dr ben carson will be speaking
to ben ferguson and it's all going to be
absolutely delusional we also have jen
saki scheduled for a press briefing at
the top of the hour super chats are
coming in francisco says david current
heavyweight champion alexander usyk is
armed with the troops in ukraine he was
living in the uk and returned to ukraine
to fight incredible
uh from the standpoint of massive dumps
how awake
not woke would you consider this cpac
conference they're barely con they're
barely conscious it's it's wild
cpac the conference for people they're
personally living nicholas cage's
character in a national treasure movie
exactly
exactly very very much so let me say
thank you to some incredible people
slotka
and humble hazard have made twitch prime
uh subscriptions at twitch numbers 18
and 19 for today today is the perfect
day to re-up or create a twitch prime
subscription remember those are free if
you have amazon prime don't let bezos
keep the money
if you have amazon prime and you're not
subscribed with twitch prime which is
free
you're just letting bezos keep the money
which is
not what i would be doing not what i
would be doing okay couple other clips
for you here's a video of marco rubio
speaking at cpac
about school's indoctrinating children
and then thomas kennedy went up to ask
him about florida republicans banning
the word gay and rubio ran away
what about what about florida school
censoring the word gay do you have
anything to say about that
do you have to say anything anything to
say about that about florida schools
censoring the word
what about canceling the word gay in
florida schools erasing gay youth
not teaching about racism in schools
legislating that oh man
you have anything to say marco rubio you
don't because you're a hypocrite yeah
oh by the way i should make sure do you
guys want me to make an announcement
about florida or florida i'll announce
both
um here's something really exciting
i am
going to be appearing
i'm going to be doing one interview in
florida and one in florida okay
in florida i will be appearing
on the patrick david podcast many of you
saying i should really be on there they
need a little bit of progressive
influence
and patrick has been nice enough to
invite me and so we are lining up the
logistics i will be appearing with
patrick bet david that's in florida then
i will drive to florida
where i will be appearing i think this
is all we're working it out
with anthony pompliano on the best
business show a rapidly another rapidly
growing youtube channel
um and so
that's all
potentially happening in march these are
both interviews with not like hard right
people but just sort of like casually
center right people who rarely talk to
progressives so i think these are pretty
big opportunities now people are saying
what about farron
fahren has nothing to do with this
farron is in a totally different part of
florida
farron is not in florida farron's in
florida he's almost in alabama okay so
um
yeah so we're gonna be uh that's gonna
be upcoming in march and uh
you can see the interviews when they air
on these respective channels uh it's
gonna be i think it should be good it'll
be really good i'm glad to get back out
there and start doing
uh doing some stuff doing some stuff i
think it's gonna be great
um
okay
uh i don't know that we really care
about this particular speech let's keep
looking at some other things
oh this is interesting
youtube continues to allow rt to
monetize their channel amid russia's
invasion of ukraine
rt is russian state television
and if you look
um
i guess i don't know that this is an
indication that they are monetized
necessarily
um
actually is it monetized i don't see any
ads i don't even know that this is true
i don't want to report something that's
untrue okay here is an ad fine here is
an ad on rt yeah rt should not be
allowed to monetize i mean they are the
people doing the invading and then they
monetize reporting on the invading that
doesn't that doesn't make any sense
that's not good
uh and then
here's another example of another one of
these lunatic right-wing defenses of
putin this guy stu peters claims when he
got sick with kovid
he claims that someone injected or
infected him with covid here's his view
on this stuff let's be real about a few
things canada cracking down on
protesters and freedom of speech seizing
truckers bank accounts matters a lot
more than
ukraine for that matter the tyranny of
our own leaders matters a lot more than
anything vladimir putin does vladimir
putin isn't forcing you to get a vaccine
vladimir putin is into platforming you
from twitter and youtube and airbnb and
seizing your bank accounts
vladimir putin isn't propagandizing your
children into cutting their genitals off
so basically this guy likes what putin's
doing because putin is transphobic
quite quite a nuanced take huh i guess i
guess we could say
um
okay
next do you think the trump
administration could be process
blackmailing the prosecutors that
resigned
i i have no evidence for that
i have no evidence that that's what's
going on
thank you to 77 degrees justin andrew
watson and sprankton
for the twitch prime subscriptions
numbers 20 21 and 22. uh yeah adam
laksalt is absolutely horrible so we're
not going to listen to him they have not
yet discussed the price of fruit
or mangoes at cpac that is that is true
i do have a bunch of different
voicemails many related to what's going
on here so let me play
uh
just a couple for you
if yours are so stupid there's like
some chick writing poetry for putin or
something
she's like ah like dude
you know
it's just like
man
wars just like really bad
okay here's another one
it concerns me david looking back when
russia wanted to do their little war
game
irish waters
that area is much closer to our nato
allies england
ireland and of course close to the
united states so
they're prepping something
perhaps
interesting
uh more just calls dumping in about
russia
so i'm watching fox news and they keep
talking about um the energy problem and
how we're getting
oil from russia
and how the sanctions aren't going far
enough because it's not stopping that do
you think that if hypothetically
if we had other things in place and we
were to stop that would that make a
difference or do you think fox news is
just blowing smoke it's a way to attack
titan and make him look bad
or do you think that actually would make
a difference uh i don't really think it
makes a difference on terms of policy
but it definitely makes a difference in
terms of the narrative the predominant
narratives that are out there for sure
ryan says thank you for all you do david
this show gives me hope some days thank
you
it's great to have you here
let's see what else we have on russia
let's see what else we've got
um
[Music]
a lot of confused voicemails
this is tony and say maybe chortle was
the right word i'm sorry
but it was fantastic david i i salute
you that was the greatest thing i've
seen
it's just absolutely fantastic and it
was so great and enlightened my heart to
see you do that and i don't know what
the caller's talking about
i really i really don't know i i'm not
sure what that's about
uh okay
hello
nice of trump to
help putin out so much huh um
good thing he let let him know that yo
the u.s would wouldn't uh
physically go in and do it
yeah trump is trump was a big help with
putin man i don't know what anybody's
talking about
uh weird
uh david pakman um the hodge twins on
youtube
they brought up a good point about the
media's portrayal of violence
i don't think that troy york has any
idea any idea
what's going on
hi david i'm catching up on your
coverage of the russia ukraine war and i
just wanted to call into one thank you
for your nuance and historic
understanding of what's happening now
wow i'm really glad that you dismantled
the notion that the west
promised russia no eastward expansion as
we know there was no formal agreement to
that but also recognizing you know that
russian
perception of what happened is also
important here
but i just wanted to add that while i
agree a hundred percent with that
analysis
another addition to this would be that
where nato and the west failed was not
in their expansion
and media her son actually tweeted an
article about this but that their
failure was to not politically and
economically integrate russia the same
way it did other former soviet republics
okay but it we can't also only blame
nato for that i mean look you know how
easy is it to integrate a place where
the egos are like putin's ego
i mean you know and say hey we want to
we want to integrate all of you
uh
ed it treated russia as just a
descendant of the soviet union the sole
defendant and they were given punitive
punishing agreements and i think it's a
lesson we should have learned from
germany after world war one where we i
mean it's a fair it's a fair voicemail i
just don't think it's completely
historically accurate but that's okay i
i love that that's a clear substantive
voicemail they're not saying anything
anti-semitic to me
and uh that's that's always a great
thing that's always a great thing
hey david it's eric from math hey i got
a question for you uh
what do you think about true social one
of their first accounts is q
yeah i tried to sign up it didn't work
and the it already seems to be
completely imploding
um tonight you were talking about the
alt left
and um i i'm personally i'm an older
listener i rarely listen to your show
anymore but tonight i heard you talk
about the alt left when you're talking
about mataibi tulsi gabbert glenn
greenwald
uh jimmy dore these are people these are
staples on rt
they're staples on fox news
when all you do when these personalities
when all they do and they that's all
they do is bash pundits and politicians
on the left i love it it is pundits not
pun dents but otherwise this is a
beautiful voicemail who is it that
they're serving david they're serving
the right wow these people are trying to
create apathy from left-leaning voters
they're trying to make you angry they
don't want you to vote i think it
who knows where they come from and who
knows who they vote for right but i
never hear any positive anything
positive come from these people
anything positive about the left coming
from these people they serve the right
they're not left by any means oh wow
what a what a strong voicemail guys very
very strong voicemail i have to say i
want to say thank you to that was based
in blue pilled thanks to fruity halo d
gudy and west grimm
for the twitch prime subscriptions
numbers 23
24
and 25. the coupon code cpac trash is
still available to anybody who wants it
kevin says via super chat i thought
trump endorsing putin would be a lot
more concerning to these freedom lovers
they really just like dictators huh they
are fundamentally reactionaries yes
exactly
david sir what will the war in ukraine
due to the price of mangoes is the biden
regime artificially driving up mango
prices look into that please i don't
think this war will have any impact on
mango prices i really don't
um
let's see what else we've got here
yeah i'm calling uh pertaining to
a technical problem i'm having with your
network
uh
david pakman show
okay okay the problem that i'm having is
that you know
i'm trying to understand
how did you become such a [ __ ] idiot
you know that's the only question i have
if you could call me and you know answer
that for me i would surely appreciate it
my name is roy 561.
whoa okay don't want to doxx this guy
but what he's saying is fascinating then
he continues on tv
i've seen a lot of idiots
anyway give me a call this is roy five
six oh god he's giving the number again
geez roy okay let's skip forward there's
people
and we also have a president that lives
here who cares about his people
and you watch it when you trash talk
donald trump you son of a [ __ ] you're a
piece of garbage you know that you're
gonna burn in hell
david pakman you look like you like to
take it up the ass oh okay so it's
homophobic guys i'm so shocked
that this devolved into homophobia you
know i didn't see i really didn't see it
coming i really didn't i i it's
it came out of nowhere that this guy's
homophobic
it just he seemed so
balanced in every way and then just out
of nowhere homophobia and it's just it's
so unpredictable
you really don't you really don't see it
um thanks to rich e brazen three
and damien brown for the twitch prime
subscriptions numbers 26 27 and 28.
i really appreciate that
um
other super chats coming in putin and
the us played tug of war over ukraine
for a long time putin saw he's losing
and he set the rope on fire yeah another
analogy is he pooped in the sandbox
because it was time for him to leave
a nathan's 1212
just got a twitch prime subscription and
is number 29. guys let's give away
another item we are at 29
number 30 meaning the next person to get
a membership on my website
joinpakman.com
even with a coupon code gets a free item
we've got coffee mugs baseball hats
t-shirts hoodies and sweatshirts okay
next person to sign up at joinpakman.com
and move this to 30 you get a free item
we'll send it to you anywhere in the
world three coupon codes available
first coupon code is cpac trash
second coupon code is please don't war
third coupon code is obama obama okay
whoever is the next person to sign up
gets the free item
um
i think russia has legitimate concerns
about nato but they have gone way too
far still nato should not increase
troops in the baltics we need peace
if russia only cared about ethnic
russians and nato expansion why does he
go after ukraine and not belarus
kazakhstan they're not democratic
beautiful question
christopher says david please clarify
your anti-war position
i can't i don't know what you want me to
clarify
war is bad guys i'm against it now i'm
toolsy no i'm i i don't know you tell me
which war but i'm against it i don't
know i
if you tell if you better can indicate
to me what it is that you want me to
clarify
i will clarify
please and thank you please and thank
you standing by for jen saki any moment
we will be getting a press briefing from
jensaki when she starts i will step away
refill my water take a five and then be
back we've got not only a long stream
but a very wide stream today
um let's see here other russia
related
voicemails
let's see what we got
is attack when i'm calling for two
reasons one please check your personal
instagram dm uh yeah i don't i don't do
that guys if you message me on discord
message me on tick tocks
message me on instagram
uh try to dm me on twitter although i
think you can't dm me unless i'm
following you i can't keep up with it we
used to get 3 000 different messages a
day we're now up to 5 000 different
messages today across all platforms i
can't respond to anybody personally so
what i can do is i'll play voicemails
if you call when we take calls i'll talk
to you there
um i hand you know eight eight or nine
emails we feature on the podcast each
week but i just can't i can't i'm sorry
guys it just doesn't work and by the way
one thing sometimes people do is
sometimes i will see emails like hey
david
could you do me a favor
do you really think i'm gonna write back
and say
yes
let me know what the favor is
so i can evaluate whether i'm able to do
the guys i i'm really busy producing the
show so uh it just i i'm sorry i'm sorry
it just it's not possible
okay new member number 30 today
is adrian subia who just signed up with
the coupon code obama and has earned a
free item from my online store adrian
please email info davidpakman.com tell
me what you'd like and where you would
like it sent you can pick from
davidpakman.com gear
has also signed up on my website jeremy
fraggerio is a new member
scott childs has signed up james harris
joseph moran
and bethany de la cruz thank you to all
six of you i really do appreciate the
support
also thanks to gramoike
and fredicini
for the twitch prime subscriptions we
are standing by here for jen saki
starting any moment we are monitoring
cpac i will be live at 6 p.m eastern
time tomorrow
tomorrow you know you know that song
with donald trump's cpac speech the
keynote
and then that's gonna do it yeah people
ask me all these favors people call and
they ask me they're like can you get me
votes i need 11 000 votes give me a
break and it's like i just can't do it i
can't do it
i i mean just
i don't know if people would find this
interesting but i do we get a lot of
emails
and we have a whole system for filing
emails and if you regularly email the
emails are automatically filtered into a
particular folder and sometimes i'll
just glance through
sometimes we get emails from people
asking me to promote their gofundmes on
the show which we you know we can't do
we get a lot of those requests we really
can't do that
um i get emails
from people
i mean i i don't even want to do it
this just we get a lot of requests that
are not reasonable a lot of requests
that are not reasonable i'm being told
that power is out in kiev oh wait a
second
it does look like power is out all of a
sudden i mean i know that it's so it's
uh
it's 10 p.m there yeah it look it does
look like power is out here
okay
oh man
this seems to be going in the wrong
direction
okay we're gonna keep monitoring that oh
look here power's on here where is this
this i okay i don't know exactly what's
going on but it's it's not great it's
not great um and we're gonna we will
keep monitoring yeah i i don't let me
see if i can get any news reports on
that
um
power
[Music]
keeve power station operating as normal
says reuters okay reuters says the power
station is okay
power station north in the north of kiev
is operating as normal after blasts were
heard
mayor vitale klitschko said five blasts
were heard in a close interval of three
to five minutes emergency service is
underway
the bridges have been taken under
protection and special control
the situation is threatening for kiev
the night close to the morning will be
very difficult yeah they seem to carry
out the vast majority of the insane
stuff
between like five and seven a.m that's
typically what we're seeing
i want to say thank you to nick yeager
who just signed up on my on my website
with the coupon code obama
knicks new member number 39 today i
really appreciate that
what will trump say tomorrow about
russia in your opinion so
i think if no one
got to trump between now and his cpac
speech he would probably say a lot of
positive things about putin
my guess is a lot of people around trump
before he speaks tomorrow night are
going to go to him and say
don't praise putin blame biden but don't
praise putin that's my guess
whether trump
goes with that
remains to be seen
that i don't i don't know the answer to
it could really that could that could
really go either way
uh okay i want to call your attention to
a twitter account
caucasus war report
which
i am being told has a lot of really good
coverage of what's going on
um
ramzan kadyrov head of the chechen
republic oh god demand zelensky
apologize to putin
yeah i don't think so guys
president
has nothing to apologize for
um captured n-law anti-tank missile
system in the hands of a russian soldier
[Applause]
ukrainian military vehicle burning in
kiev city as the owner of the video says
the vehicles are being targeted by ucavs
meaning russia is actively using drone
technology
okay a lot of very crazy stuff that's
the twitter account caucasus war report
and you can you can check that out
um if you are interested
it does look like
i mean listen
in the top right and bottom left i see
essentially no evidence of of electric
electricity in the back here it looks
like there is some light
uh i don't know about you guys i'm just
calling it like i see it
um
there were rumors that power was out in
kiev but reuters put out a report that a
particular power station that had been
targeted is still functioning but here
it's almost looking like it's just
people with uh okay here's the so it's a
car
this down here may be flashlights it's
hard to tell
we don't know
we're receiving these reports
you know in in real time
uh they may be turning lights off to
hide where people are yes that that's a
strategy that was used in uh in the uk
in fact in london during world war ii
famously so famously so
uh yeah
where are you getting reports about
power in ukraine
for just we're seeing we're seeing
anecdotal tweets
saying it's off and that it's on
what are the current communications
between trump and putin and what has he
told them we are not aware of any
communication between trump and putin at
this time
if anybody has
contradictory information on that then
by all means you can let me know but
we're not aware of any such
communication right now
thanks to chris mose for the twitch
prime subscription you are number 40
today and i really appreciate your
support let's listen to a couple more
voicemails here
um
okay
let's see what else we have
hey david's mo pablo and nieces listen i
was just wondering a few months back
uh china made
um
over china
saying
in regards to um
suggesting possibly nuclear accident
then uh putin did the same thing what
yesterday two days ago
so i'm wondering what the what what how
you feel
the uh
implications are of that and
yeah it's not clear what putin meant and
so i don't i don't really want to
speculate about that
hi yeah
okay
david i have the perfect solution to
this conflict between russia and the
ukraine it's just ukraine deploy some
people down there
and teach both sides of the conflict
critical race theory there you go
because then they'll feel guilty about
the color of their skin
and they'll be so guilty that they'll
just kind of withdraw and like lay in
bed all day and get depressed
that's not bad actually that's not a bad
idea and neither side will have the will
to fight we won't have to worry about
russian hot there's nothing as
dispiriting for morale as being taught
critical race theory yeah that's fair
aggression taking over parts of the
europe
uh by parts of europe by force
and yeah all right i get it that's not a
bad idea yeah just just teach them
critical race theory perfect perfect
uh
okay we're standing by for a press
briefing from jen saki in the meantime
uh ben carson and ben ferguson are going
to be having a conversation i'm going to
take a five let's listen and i'll be
right back with everybody we're seating
right here we followed directions well
didn't we
i think we need a little bit bigger
round of applause for america's real
doctor
so so hold on hold on we're going to try
something
you know they say that conservatives
don't have technology okay
pay attention hey conservative siri what
is the name of this show
the ben's show there we go
[Music]
who says we can't compete doc
how are you i'm doing extremely well
running up and down the the highway and
the airways i was in
colorado springs this morning where it
was two below zero
so
welcome to florida right i don't know
why everybody doesn't live in florida
[Applause]
trust me have you seen the number of
u-hauls coming in the state they're
working on it a thousand people a day so
i was sitting there the other day
watching the super bowl i knew you and i
were gonna do the ben show and i thought
to myself i'm like man this halftime
show i know ben carson's getting down
who was your favorite
i always root for the winner there you
go i like it
i like it all right i want to get into a
you know everybody's been focused on
ukraine
uh everybody's been dealing with foreign
policy there's another crisis in this
country right now and you know every
time i see fauci speak i think i wish
ben carson was that guy
[Music]
i would love it wouldn't you love it if
ben carson had that gig
so whoever runs next time i have a
feeling whoever that person is might
have been or be in this building
you you heard the crowd i think you know
what your next gig may be
i am genuinely shocked and concerned in
the medical community i grew up as you
know in memphis tennessee right saint
jude children's research hospital is
there um
my wife's entire career was at st jude
and you see researchers get together
and you see them get it right you see
them get it wrong you see them share
information you see them collaborate
it's what you do as a doctor
why is it now that we don't even see
that and not only that we are trying to
ruin doctors careers who disagree or say
something different on anything that the
federal government dr fauci or any of
these dictators and tyrants the american
community demand that they shut up and
be quiet did you ever witness anything
like this in your life and did you ever
think you would know i must admit that
even i am surprised that
the level to which
medicine has sunk
because not following science claiming
to follow science but being completely
unscientific science
will actually ask questions about
benefits versus risk they will actually
look at collateral
effects of things
so when you take something like covet
which by the way
even though they don't want to let it go
it is going away because
you know the
the good lord has a way of taking care
of things so he says
since they don't seem to have the
ability to understand what's going on
and they just want to manipulate it i'll
just make this thing get weaker and
weaker and more contagious pretty soon
everybody will have it it'll be endemic
and it'll be gone and they won't be able
to make it last until november
until until another election right
until another see we're making headlines
folks ben carson just said code will be
gone by november
write it down
um
let's talk about fauci and and and i
don't want to i'm not talking about the
politics okay i'm talking about the
medical side of this
the job of dr fauci and anyone in that
position should be non-political it
should be if you did a poll on factory
right now i believe he's probably more
polarizing than even donald trump is at
any point in his political career dr
fauci and that position is not supposed
to be political
how does a man like that
stay there knowing that he's lost the
country
and and i say this from the standpoint
of we're going to need medical advice on
something else down the road you've seen
all the different you know the history
of disease right you understand how
important is to have doctors that have a
platform to speak in a non-political
dictator type way
i'm worried that we're gonna face
something much greater than covid one
day and no one's gonna listen to the
people in charge because they say i
didn't i shouldn't have listened to him
last time and unfortunately you've hit
the nail on the head there
you know there's a tremendous loss of
confidence
in our government and in our government
medical facilities the cdc the nih
because they've allowed themselves
to be manipulated and controlled by
other forces now you take something like
like what happened with covet and they
needed to get an emergency use
authorization at eua
we have a silly rule in place
that says you can't get the eua if there
are other effective treatments and
that's why
they denigrated
hydroxychloroquine
even though oh you're going to be
careful with that word now that's like a
four letter word in this country well
it's a very good four-letter word
i'm just making sure our mics are still
working you said hydroxy cork all right
we're still on because if if you go to
western
africa go to places like nigeria
there's almost no covet throughout this
whole thing why because they take
hydroxychloroquine as an anti-malarial
now are they doing hydroxy disinfo i'm
just getting back science
that would have piqued our interest
would have said why is that the case why
in some parts of india is there almost
no
covet because they were taking
ivermectin wrong all these are all lies
this is all lies first of all in some
parts of india there was no covid for a
while because it just didn't get there
yet then it completely exploded ivor
mechtin has been studied in a in a
randomized controlled trial
peer-reviewed it does not work for covid
all of this we know we have data we know
all of the stuff now we use it's great
to have the data now by the way what is
ben ferguson wearing
whoops intense and then you take
children you know i've spent my whole
children as a pediatric neurosurgeon and
being concerned about what happens with
our children right they have for healthy
child
the
incidence of death from covet is 0.025
hallelujah that's approaching zero but
we have no idea
what the long-term effect of these spike
proteins are going to be on them so
we're trading no almost no he's acting
like we know the long-term effects of
covid too i mean this this guy is a
doctor and he's completely completely
fallen for all of it three i've got a
five-year-old
and i have obviously doing a radio show
a podcast every day
you take a lot of heat from people
because i said i'm not giving my kids
the vaccine
because i don't understand why i would
do some crowds cheering when you just
talk to the facts in fact if you go to
the cdc's own website they say my child
has a bigger chance of dying from the
flu
than they do from covet yeah well if so
am i a bad parent for saying being
skeptical of this mandate of you must
vaccinate your child or you're the worst
by the way ben ferguson is almost
irrecognizable uh he and i mean listen
guys i'll just be the difference is he
seems to have doubled in size uh he is
almost irrecognizable here people for
instance not ridiculing obesity or
anything i'm just i barely recognize the
guy children i mean where did these
people come from
and
it's probably school systems mostly
big attack on public schools there
everybody should just pay to send their
kids to private school wearing
particularly at a young age when you're
trying to develop your sociological uh
image of yourself
and a lot of that is because of positive
feedback that you get by looking at
people's facial expressions
we're going to end up with a whole
generation of pathological people who
don't know how to interact with each
other yeah they're called trumpists look
at this and we already have a lot of
errors going on you look at the number
of emergency room
visits by children year over year
2020 to 2021
psychiatric emergencies have gone up 40
in the first uh
three quarters
of those years that have been looked at
i want to i want to take a p did you
guys notice how what he's it's it's
almost impossible to fact check that
because he's being so unclear
psychiatric emergencies have gone up 20
in the first three quarters that have
been looked at
what
that that's not it's not even an it's
that's not a complete empirical
statement
that the government is paying for your
free vaccine oh he said 40 i thought he
said
20. yeah are we paranoid or are we
brilliant doctor i think the american
people are some of the smartest people
in the world
if you give them the facts if you let
them work with them they're when i was
running for it i'd be worried about big
formulas
what about teaching them
to be able to ascertain on their own
what sort of assertions are trustworthy
bro no no no no that we don't want to do
the vaccine if you go get the vaccine
i'm not anti-vaxxed but don't tell me
it's free no it's when i paid for it
through my tax dollars it's a wonderful
thing for them to be told that as much
of this as you can make we're gonna buy
it
you know so they've never had an
opportunity like that before and are
taking advantage of it and i'm sorry to
see that
now there are so let's see they're
4-hydroxychloroquine
4-ivermectin against the government
pre-purchasing vaccines against
vaccinating children so far this is this
is what they've espoused
most of the people are logical
they're good people
but
they have a tendency to stand in the
corner with their head down
hoping that nobody calls them a nasty
name very low energy do that it's time
for people to speak up for what they
believe in because we are save our
country we are yeah
we mentioned trust earlier and you've
dealt with pandemics
and this is the one that my generation's
gonna has has has been carson dealt with
pandemics as a doctor what is what is
ben ferguson talking about what does
that mean you've dealt if you're
interviewing a doctor and you say you've
dealt with pandemics it sounds like
you're saying as a doctor you've dealt
with pandemics but
no he hasn't he was a neurosurgeon what
is he talking about with pronunciation
i don't think you can put on on paper
how bad it is going to be for several
sure jenner several different grades in
this generation that lost years of
education and years of basic learning
we're talking about kids that should be
speaking they're saying that can't see
their parents faces and their teachers
faces because the mask and it's
affecting them what data from a from a
doctor standpoint that deals with kids
and pediatrics are you worried about
he's a neurosurgeon he doesn't know
anything about that imagine what it must
be like to be a little kid
you have to wear a mask you don't get to
see facial expressions
then you're told you may be harboring
some deadly disease you may not be sick
but you may give it to your grandmother
and she may die well grandmothers do get
older and they do die now you're feeling
happy about that if you're white you're
told that you're an oppressor and you're
the cause of all minorities problems if
you're a minority you're told that
you're a victim all of this is happening
while you're trying to develop your
self-image is ben carson
does do you guys think he believes this
i don't think he could possibly believe
this crap i think he's just telling
these stories to the crowd
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that deserves a standing ovation i mean
that's the line of the day right there
we'll get taken out of context don't
worry someone will write an article
about it i didn't even hear the line
you you see what we're doing and you
brought it up so i'm going there
is it child abuse
what we're watching happen politically
now to kids
with this
transgenderism
he's a neurosurgeon he doesn't know
anything about that which is i want to
make sure i'm right it's never happened
in the history of the world
not that i know
okay we'd really be breaking some news
is it child abuse in your opinion to to
be raising kids in this world with
hormone blockers and doing that to a
child a young age because i think it is
of course it's child abuse but
i don't want
people to get off that easily by just
calling it child abuse
we all have spheres of influence
and we have to stand up against this we
have to be aware of what's being taught
to our children in the preschool they
have these books about these worms and
they say these worms can be male or
female they get to choose and they make
these worms seem like really cool
individuals
and
what are they doing they are planting
seeds
and this is a terrible thing
that they're doing i don't know whether
carson rates higher on evil or stupidity
i i genuinely am unsure our
kindergartners first second third
graders are looking at
they have
naked people in them
doing all kinds of
things that
people shouldn't know about at that age
and
they are affecting the character of our
children at a time of innocence when
you're supposed to be having fun and
developing
and
you know we talk about things like
how our
our system is systemically racist and
it's keeping people from achieving i'll
tell you what's keeping people from
achieving
now about the worms there are worms that
are like
hermaphroditic and can and i think they
can they can switch genders or something
like that like is it possible that the
worm story is just scientifically
accurate is that possible
as we wrap the ben show
conservative siri do we have more uh 30
more seconds
she didn't all right there the audience
decided for the benz show yes for the
ben show do we have 30 more seconds
conservative siri
45 yes
[Applause]
mask mandates my last and final guys the
right's getting better at comedy and
it's making me nervous like mandates
but i also know there's cause and effect
yeah
your thoughts on mass mandates in the
country well they're basically over
that's one of the reasons that we
developed american cornerstone institute
faith
liberty
community and life people came to this
country from all over the world because
they didn't want people to be mandating
what they had to do they wanted to live
the lives they wanted to live this is a
principle of this nation we cannot let
it go we must not convolution plasma i
get arrested on my flight home i'm
blaming dr ben carson he said i didn't
need to wear my mask
give him a give america doctor a big
round of applause
maybe he'll be our dr fauci one day
that concludes the bend show god bless
you guys
wow
what a genuinely stupid segment i mean
this is this is bad even for cpac this
is this is genuinely bad even for cpac
um
wow
okay let's see what's next
uh
yeah nigel farage is speaking there's a
bunch of what really really horrifying
stuff coming up we're standing by for
gensake
um
oh god it's matt schlopp thanks for
correctly pronouncing keeve was watching
some eu news and they were still using
the old pronunciation kiev drove me nuts
love the show thank you do these two
actually even believe what they're
saying yeah that was my question i don't
know i don't know
let's see what's happening over in
ukraine there were rumors of power
outages but it's not clear now
light seems to be on
i don't know what the upper left is
someone preparing pasta
but
okay
let's see how the stock market is
looking like it's going to wrap up today
a big up day as we might say in the
business yeah
looking looking pretty strong there
uh we're going to be hearing any moment
here from jen saki
i want to say thank you to
hold on who do i want to say i guess no
one yeah no i don't have anybody i don't
have anybody to think but welcome to all
of our new twitch viewers as well as
youtube
facebook
the schedule is that tomorrow at 6 p.m
eastern
i will be live for donald trump's cpac
speech
tuesday at 8 00 p.m eastern i will be
live for joe biden's state of the union
address so we have a lot of very
exciting things going on um it's true
what doc dr carson said
i'm trans because as a child i was
forced to read books about being a cool
worm yeah i know it's uh it's really
very very dangerous very dangerous why
am i using the old pronunciation of
pasta no i i say pasta but i know some
of our british friends say pasta
and i don't i don't dislike it
i don't dislike it one bit
um how do i sign up for twitch prime oh
no
okay
if you have amazon prime
amazon gives you a free twitch prime
subscription amazon owns twitch from the
standpoint of ownership and so if you
have amazon prime once a month you can
get a free twitch prime subscription and
it's a beautiful thing and it's really a
shame more people don't do it
um hers of fat just did it
for the eighth month in a row and is
number 41. i really appreciate that
any coupon codes yes but the coupon
codes don't work on twitch sometimes i
get emails from people and they say
david i i did everything i could i
couldn't find where to enter the code
obama
on twitch there are no coupon codes on
twitch
twitch prime is free you don't need a
code because it's free
if you have amazon prime
the coupon codes are at joinpackman.com
how do i use my mouse oh guys i can't do
it i can't do it no i can't do that um
the coupon code cpac trash works at
joinpakman.com these are all different
systems
different systems
um
okay let's listen to a little bit of
this as we wait for jen saki
and if you think about it
luckily they work for me
my response was we're going to help you
we're going to find a way to help you
we're not going to let you suffer like
this
senator we've uh
we've received a lot of phone calls at
our house obviously these people were
colleagues with mercy at the white house
or at the presidential campaign and uh
some of these are people are awfully
junior staffers
uh to president trump or to others
and uh they know nothing about any
illegal activity they had no involvement
in any illegal activity they love their
country they want to serve their country
some of these people are saying we can't
even get a lawyer think about this and a
lot of i'm sure we have people that know
the legal profession well
they can't even get a lawyer to
represent them in america because these
law firms have gone so
woke and left-wing that the committee
that runs give me a break dude here's an
interesting super chat
google the pronunciation of obfuscate
all right is it is it different than how
i'm saying it
let's see the pronunciation
uh obfuscate oh it's obfuscate not
obfuscate obfuscate
that does not sound natural to me
that doesn't sound at all natural to me
obfuscate obfuscate i say obfuscate i
think i'm going to keep keep doing it
language is quite pliable
i want to say thank you to a bunch of
people supporting via twitch prime those
people are angry guido
beezus
zakatak
brookie
luis
millergamie and obishan
kenobi
seven people putting us at 48. i really
appreciate that very much
david first time long time thank you for
the love streams when will we see your
beautiful hairy chest and manly
argentinian arms
uh what have you and things of this
nature we're looking into that very
strongly
we're looking into that very strongly
i don't i don't have an answer right now
but it is something we are
considering considering
long list of recommendations to improve
security at the capitol the capitol
police have been implementing that for
over a year now
that's what you would suspect you know
what you would expect the commission to
do the inspector general of the capitol
has been involved in that
that's a responsible approach to this
but nancy pelosi didn't get what she
wanted out of it which is the political
fodder imagine carrying what hagerty
believes
uh larry says cpac seems as crazy as
ever but at least the stage wasn't the
shape of a hate symbol this year much
love from new york city i also pronounce
it obfuscate rather than obfuscate
yeah
i am looking at getting a hot tub
installed right in the studio so we
could do a hot tub stream certainly open
to that
um
let me see what else i've got for you
guys oh a couple other super chats yeah
voicemails rather
let's see
if i have anything here
hi david uh i was just wondering if
there are any words or phrases that in
your day to day to uh
you start supplementing in your head
like um for me if anybody ever says
origins
my brain is like oranges yep you know
cause because it's like everything that
the whole
yeah take a look at the oranges of the
investigation uh any time my girlfriend
says hey can you look at something with
me later i say let's look at it very
strongly and it just she just doesn't
care it doesn't matter but i i laugh to
myself
um let's see what else we have here
i did uh i was watching a little bit of
fox news over there and they kept
talking about the energy situation and
the fact that russia controls a lot of
the gas and oil supply do you think
uh joe biden's doing the right thing by
not trying to
control that and trying to
like fox news is saying that we should
open up the pipeline and start um
producing ourselves what's your thoughts
on that thanks bye
yeah i mean i kind of don't really care
what fox news thinks but obviously there
are realities here about
the sources of energy
and uh the fact that there are pipelines
that russia controls
that go through ukraine
it's a very complicated issue i wouldn't
pay particularly close attention to what
fox news uh says about it
so
benjamin was talking about
naval gazing rich people
and it's like a lot of those people are
like my friends and allies and stuff
like that you know like
they're making them suicidal with this
whole like
you know oh
the abortion is
a
um
a baby
and then
like forcing people to have sex with
them yeah
uh let's see what else we have here
yeah i'm calling about the us
or
russia threatens u.s assets in response
to sanctions
um
from a military guy i don't think
anybody should be losing any sleep over
that
any threats
that he is going to do
or actually trying man barely audible
truly barely audible
what else do we have here
a lot a lot of different things
happening
anything on russia
hey david uh sherry ellison brand new
member welcome um watching or trying to
watch
this cpac coverage i have to tell you
that
if their way of organizing
this conference uh is any indication of
whom they are why in god's green earth
should we trust them with anything they
can't even get their own act together
their own show
i mean am i right or am i wrong you are
right sherry beautifully said i couldn't
possibly say it better myself the
background noise is just the press room
we're just trying to keep an eye on on
when that's starting
jesse says good day sir circling back on
january 7th you said you learned how to
say raleigh when growing up in belgium
yeah it's a joke it was just a joke guys
why on earth would so raleigh or rally i
don't even know how to say is a city in
north carolina
whoa what's going on
so it was just a joke obviously growing
up in belgium would not help me know how
to say that and i apologize it was my
dry humor
and uh nobody got it nobody got it and i
apologize for that let me say thank you
to yaako yaks podcast
rdnys bite the asp
and pink and blonde four people
who just became twitch prime subscribers
i really appreciate that guys really
very very much i really it's uh i could
not possibly appreciate it more
i never understand anything whitney says
but i'm amazed at how many things she
finds to call you about i know
i know let's just see let's find one
other topic that whitney called about
just just to see
um
just to see what else is on whitney's
mind
okay here's one
so i might have some really good advice
as far as being jewish and i don't know
whether it's good or not so i'm gonna
put it out there and then if it's bad
advice for jews or advice to become
jewish i don't really know what she
means just ignore it
but um so what i was thinking is that i
took a look at like the philosophy of
being jewish
and i was thinking that
not going for people who were like
really good at acting or
um
you know uh
necessarily get good grades or better
looking than everybody
i think like
the perfect jewish person would be
somebody who's like extremely good at
improv
yes the jewish tradition of
improvisational comedy
very interesting insights here
from
whitney
see what else we've got here
it's it's it's wild out there i want
everybody to be very very careful
obviously
uh because it's
it's really something else
hey david uh i have to say my favorite
part of all the cpac thing that we watch
is actually while you were gone um dr
carson
was talking about how everything has
gone away from being scientific how like
they claim it's science but it's the
whole thing about science questions and
then he said and then
he said uh and you know god has a way of
fixing things because that is the most
scientific thing i've ever heard oh my
god did he really say that that's insane
that's bonkers chandra says a hot tub
for the studio must be because you make
money from a bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad right
david sir why should anyone take you
seriously you're not a knight at the
round table you are pro biden mango
inflation yeah that's absolutely true i
am not a knight at the round table he's
not a knight at the round table
right
right
david sir i think i speak for everyone
when i say your audience would greatly
appreciate a hot tub steam from the
standpoint of enjoyment
david sir what is the philosophy of
being jewish whitney has confused me i
don't know what she was talking about
guys yeah i'm sorry
i genuinely don't know what that was
about it was very odd very very odd as
we continue to stand by for
white house press secretary jen saki
let's see if we have any updates
from
ukraine of kiev and we are not going
anywhere there was a very important
message as well because there were
rumors today during the day that
zininski might not be in kiev and
he just needed to do that also to say
that was not true and to confirm that he
is and he's not going to go anywhere and
to say how defiant and how resistant the
people are and he's there to support
them
and
what is the ukrainian media then saying
about this current situation and of
course the foreign response
all right the press briefing is starting
press briefing is starting
and cpac is back with just a random guy
okay so we're gonna stay here
um
let's see what's going on see if there's
any further announcements about anything
i assume that there will be
it does appear as though russia has been
pushing further into ukraine at this
point in time we hope to get an update i
want to say thanks to under the screen
for the twitch prime subscription you're
number 53 today very very much
appreciate that
see what else we've got
there was a two minute warning so it
should be starting any second
we'll be back tomorrow 6 pm eastern for
trump's cpac speech that's correct
should be
horrifying to be absolutely horrifying
you never know what trump's going to say
every time he speaks people are flushing
toilets 10 times 15 times
someone's going to wilmington in the
morning that's
interesting
guests next week yeah let me see who
we've got lined up
uh next week we've got
oh heath drewson on actually uh being
with a bunch of these kind of like
militia types
he was fully integrated
tom hartman will be with us soon
guys we got thomas homer dixon thomas
homer dixon's the canadian um a
political scientist who said the u.s
could be a dictatorship by 2030. we got
him ladies and gentlemen we got him and
he's going to be on with us soon
[Applause]
i don't even know how to pronounce that
but i appreciate the twitch prime
subscription thank you
uh very very much appreciative of that
let's see if we can squeeze in one more
voicemail before jen saki let's see
hi david i want to talk about the timing
of this attack
by russia on ukraine
so
one of the things you would hear about
trump more and more um especially uh
for his first impeachment is uh what is
now called russia gate
and i think it's been pushed more
towards the kind of
uh
fringe uh left i think the general
kind of defense making in the united
states is that russiagate
was more uh
made out to be more than it actually was
no
russiagate is the view that there were
people saying trump will will be caught
dead to rights on video colluding with
putin and of course no one was actually
saying that
all right
uh i just have one item for all of you
no one's serious ahead i know there are
a few topics to discuss uh today during
our time together uh on monday the
president will host a celebration to
mark black history month he will be
joined by the vice president black
members of the historically diverse
cabinet members of the congressional
black caucus state and local elected
officials civil rights leaders and
divine nine leadership on tuesday as you
are all tracking the president will
deliver his first state of the union
address we will have more of his address
to preview uh in the coming days on
wednesday the president and the first
lady will travel to superior wisconsin
to discuss how the bipartisan
infrastructure law delivers for the
american people by rebuilding roads and
bridges and creating good paying union
jobs and on thursday the president will
hold a cabinet meeting with that see if
when it should kick us off
uh the eu earlier today agreed to hold
uh to replace uh sanctions and asset
phrases on the election president
and uh
let's switch to a feed where we can see
the reporters
sanctions and nasa phrases on the
russian president putin
and uh and the russian foreign minister
is the united states going to fall
asleep
following a television a telephone
conversation a president biden held with
uh european commission president ursula
vonderline and in alignment with the
decision by our european allies the
united states will join them in
sanctioning president putin and foreign
minister lavrov and members of the
russian national security team that's
beautiful we'll have more specific
details out later this year i'd love to
see it thanks um
can you detail the level of support the
united states government is currently
providing operationally to the ukrainian
military and intelligence services that
they try to fend off the russian
invasion is the u.s continuing to send
uh weaponry into ukraine because it's
providing intelligence
russian movements and practical
communications real life well without
getting into too many specific details
that are sensitive for a range of
reasons
we are continuing to deliver on the
security assistance package that was
announced
earlier last fall all of that has not
been delivered yet we're continuing to
provide that assistance obviously we are
rema we remain in very close touch of
course with uh with president zielinski
i think you may have just seen the
readout that we just put out that
included the president spoke with him
earlier today again and we are in very
close touch from our national security
team with members of his team as well
and we continue to uh to
consider a range of options to provide
additional assistance right president
last night said he was
target number one uh of the russian
military
does the united states have sort of have
a warning to russia in the event that
you know
that they were to target the ukrainian
president or attempt to capture him or
to
physically harm him
do we have a warning to them
well
well let me first say that we have been
uh warning for months that
uh
for weeks if not months that key falling
that attempts to overturn the leadership
of ukraine is very much in the
aspirations of president putin
so his their attempts to do exactly that
and their uh continued uh progress in
moving toward kiev and moving toward
ukrainian leadership is aligned with
what we have predicted
obviously going after the head of state
would be a significant
horrific act
by
russian leadership but we remain in
contact as you
all have seen from the readout we
provided with president zielenski he's
made clear that he's still in ukraine
proudly and courageously standing up in
the face of the russian attack
and we are certainly continue to be con
concerned about the ongoing russian
assault on the
country topic uh the centers for disease
control prevention uh right now is
announcing new uh
federal mass guidelines uh that uh
including under them 70 or so of
americans right now live in areas where
they are no longer recommended to wear
masks and doors and public settings
right is that a guidance that will be
followed here in the white house's
washington dc is now not only
recommended anymore for wearing them
sure well we are evaluating our
protocols obviously this guidance is
just going out now as we speak i believe
dr wolenski continues to provide a
briefing call with some of your
colleagues right now dc currently has a
mask mandate until march first we've
always followed the most stringent
guidelines that has typically been the
cdc so we will plan to follow that and
in the meantime we will we are
evaluating our protocols here at the
white house
on president zelinski did uh in the then
presidential phone call with him did it
come up whether president biden bring up
whether president
he thinks he should leave the country or
not
uh
that that is not i don't have any
additional details to provide president
zielinski continues to serve as
president of ukraine he continues to do
that courageously in the face of attacks
from russian military this was a call
for the president to reiterate our
strong support for him for the ukrainian
people and to reiterate and condemn the
actions of the russians and on
sanctioning putin and lavrov yesterday
president biden had said that that was
on the table what changed between
yesterday and today well it has been
under consideration and on the table for
some time as you know and
as i just conveyed
the president's uh strong view and and
strong principle from the beginning of
this conflict and even before i should
say has been to take actions and steps
in alignment with our european partners
and this is certainly evidence of that
just finally on that one what does
sanctioning putin himself do in this the
opinion of this administration a lot of
analysts have said that this is more of
a symbolic move than anything well
without getting into any specific
details i know you're not exactly asking
me this but sort of about financial
assets etc i will leave that to others
to speak to uh certainly the united uh
uh this step that we are doing in
alignment uh and in coordination with
the europeans just sends a clear message
about uh the the strength of the
opposition uh to the actions uh by
president putin and the direction uh in
his leadership of the russian military
yeah i just wanted to ask and the
continuing questions on sanctions
today we said that the italian
government and the german government
both expressed it said very clearly that
they would not veto
a move to remove russia from the swift
transaction system
can you say word about how quickly you
think something like that would happen
and whether you believe that that would
be another productive tool and perhaps
another moment you know symbolic uh or
rather an important measure sure well um
again
the president's principle is doing
taking steps in alignment we are
stronger together especially as we stand
in the face of the uh russian military's
actions and and their invasion of
ukraine as it relates to swift we've
never taken that off the table of course
and i'm certainly not taking it off the
table today so certainly there'll be
ongoing discussions about that as you
know swift is a messaging service that
connects 11 000
banks and
many would argue that um there are ways
that um that russia the russian
leadership could get around that over
the course of time but it certainly
remains an option on the table in terms
of the timeline i don't have anything to
predict for you on that
we were uh also reported today that
china has actually increased its
reserves as opposed to releasing
reserves which could help perhaps with
the energy price increases that we're
seeing have you uh had you know what do
you what do you think of that move and
then also has there been any
further communication does president uh
biden intend to talk to president xi or
can you say word about what what you're
doing in terms of trying to convince the
chinese to be supportive well i i would
note that um also today the i the iea
had an informal meeting where they
discussed options they could take over
the coming days and weeks to help
address
any
volatility in the global markets and
you know the heightening of price
volatility and certainly that meeting
today was a chance to consult and
continue coordination with partners on
global energy supply and security
there's also continuing conversations
that we have had from here with partners
over the past day secretary granholm
spoke with french german eu and uk
counterparts yesterday and will continue
those conversations as it relates to
china uh you know i would say that uh
the president's view of course is that
now is the time for leaders of the world
to not just speak out clearly against
president putin's flagrant aggression
and to stand with the people of ukraine
uh but this is not a moment for ev
equivocation or hiding or waiting to see
what happens next it is already clear
what's happening and as a part of that
it's also important to be a part of the
effort to
mitigate and minimize the impact on
global markets and global oil markets
and so i don't have any additional
conversations to read out for you but i
would say certainly uh we all want to be
part of the solution here and stand up
in the face of aggression to help
address the problems are you saying that
china is in fact equivocating
all i'm saying is that every country
should think about what side of history
they want to be on here and they have
the ability to do that
go ahead when did president biden make
the final decision to sanction president
it was made it's been on the table for
some time but through coordination and
discussion with our european partners
over the last
day or so so he decided
in the last 24 hours that he was going
to do that again it's been on the table
for some time his priority and his focus
has been on taking steps in coordination
and obviously that decision was made
over the course of the last 24 hours and
in in partnership with our european
counterparts does it include a travel
ban by chance uh i believe that would be
a part of the u.s component yes so
president food would be banned from
traveling here there's more details of
it that again will be out later today uh
there are very limited examples of this
being done as you all know um but that
is a standard part but again there'll be
more details we'll have available later
today another question on travel the uk
is banning civilian russian aircraft
from its airspace saying that no
aircraft on a service owned operated or
chartered chartered by a person
connected with russia shall fly in their
airspace is the united states planning
to do the same
i'm not aware of that being in the plans
but i don't have anything to preview for
you okay and another question we've seen
these predictions from the defense
department from the state department
about
keem falling to russia yeah they've made
clear that they believe that is in
putin's sites and that he wants to
overthrow the government there
if that happens what does the us do what
is the response in the world that the
united states takes population
well i would just reiterate as we've
been warning for months um that key
falling is a real possibility and we've
continued to see
russia's
progression even as we've seen
resistance on the ground uh russians
military contin russia's military
continues to advance toward kiev so
there is that real possibility i'm just
not going to get into at this point
hypotheticals of what that will look
like or what our response would be thank
you go ahead thank you jen i just want
to follow up on the putin sanctions
again
based on what you've said so far so was
this decision to coordinate with allies
meant to show unity
meant to show that putin is a pariah or
do you think it will actually have
an impact on putin in practice given the
uncertainty about the extent and
location of his wealth sure i understand
what you're asking i'm just not going to
get into specifics about his financial
assets from here again i think what is
important and what we are hoping the
world takes away from this is the uh
unity uh through which the united states
president biden is working uh with our
european partners and allies without
getting into details can you even say if
this will or will not impact him other
than showing that he's you know
an outlier again i'm not going to get
into his personal financial assets
that's typically not something we would
do from here but i would note again that
the steps that were taken yesterday and
announced yesterday uh
sanctioning uh the 10 largest financial
10 of the largest financial institutions
in russia accounting for a huge
percentage of their banking capacity uh
what of their financial system capacity
i should say and even the anticipation
what we'll do see ask is president biden
ready to personally go in to rescue
zolensky and if not why not skyrocketing
inflation in russia and we also have
taken steps to sanction oligarchs around
president putin people who have
benefited from
corruption and cronyism in the system
and even their family members to prevent
them from having the capacity to move
around their assets and on the supreme
court today of the day um
it was exactly two years ago today that
the president made a pledge that he
would nominate a black woman to the
supreme court did he factor the timing
of that into his decision to announce it
today no what
um and then can you share any details
about the process sure now that it's
over finally we're free uh like you know
how long the interview or interviews
were
what they talked about what led the
president to choose
judge jackson over the other candidates
sure well i will share with you the
details that we're comfortable sharing
at this point in time and obviously
judge jackson will have
be filling out a range of questionnaires
she will be testifying she will be
considered by the full senate and she
will be asked a range of questions there
the president interviewed judge jackson
judge childs and judge krueger on monday
february 14th in person
he made his final decision and called
judge jackson last night
last evening this is one of the
prototypical questions where everyone's
just playing their role like listen what
do you think he did he got
recommendations
he evaluated the individuals in terms of
whether they were likely to sort of have
like skeletons in their closet that
could be a problem a review was done of
their credentials some people who know
them were interviewed biden spoke to
them and he got the opinions of some of
the people in the senate that he trusts
like
you know what it's one of those things
where like it ha it's almost like it has
to be asked it has to be answered
everybody knows the answer all the
normal stuff was done childs to let them
know that he had chosen judge jackson i
don't have any other details on that uh
but i can tell you that he called judge
jackson to offer her the to tell her he
was going to nominate her last evening
go ahead thank you jen the state
department just said about the us and
russia that there are still some areas
in which the fulfillment of our national
security priorities and imperatives
require us to engage and co-exist how is
it that we are still
engaging and coexisting with the
russians well peter i would say
diplomacy around the world requires us
to engage with countries even where we
have strong disagreements strong
opposition strong condemnation we have
been very outspoken and taken actions
against china's human rights abuses but
we have worked with them in other
capacities we are working russia as a
part of the p5 plus one as we're working
and making progress on an iran nuclear
deal there's no question that
achievement of that would make the world
safer so it is our responsibility
and diplomacy means engaging even with
countries where you have strong
disagreement and strong opposition and
just so that we can understand then the
approach that means that you guys will
sit here and sanction vladimir putin and
then send diplomats to go sit on the
same side of the table with
the russians
to hash out the aranja is that what's
happening that's right peter but i don't
know why you sound so skeptical what our
job here in the united states and from
any government is to take steps that are
in the interests of the american people
and the united states of america
and part of that is would certainly be
reducing iran's capacity and ability to
have a nuclear weapon i think there's no
question about that russia is a part of
the p5 plus one okay there's a report in
the new york times that you guys kept
asking china to help you stop russia
from invading ukraine
and they didn't so
what have you guys done
throughout this slow-moving russian
crisis
that has worked
in what capacity well the president
talked to putin he talked to the g7 he
threatened sanctions he put sanctions in
place now he says the sanctions guys
like what have you hai's done you guys
think the people in ukraine have about a
month well peter let me just take a step
back and explain to everyone how
diplomacy works and how our approach
from the united states has worked
what the president has done is he has
built a global coalition
to stand up in the face of president
putin and president putin's aggression
and invasion of ukraine what he has done
is he has rallied the world our eu
european partners even at cost to them
in some capacities
they spent four years saying we should
be friends with putin and now they're
like why didn't biden do enough sooner
and it's only up to the us whether
russia invades
it is president putin's choice to go to
war and invade ukraine that is what he
has done it is our choice and our
responsibility and the role of the
president in the united states to rally
opposition and make sure they feel
significant pain from that choice that's
exactly what we have done and i
understand that you're saying that these
sanctions will have an impact on russia
but what good does that do these people
in ukraine who are
seeing the news and these u.s intel
assessments
is going to fall
any day
well peter first of all we are the
largest provider of humanitarian
assistance of security assistance
in the world to the ukrainian to the
ukrainian government which still stands
and support and the biggest supporter of
the ukrainian people and we will
continue to be and we are leading this
global effort to stand up against the
aggression of president putin and so we
are doing the president is doing nearly
everything in his power to lead the
world and stand up against the actions
of president putin what he will not do
is send u.s troops to fight in ukraine
because he is not going to put the
american uh public the american people
or the united states in a position of
fighting a war with russia go ahead if i
can ask you about we've been watching a
lot of the pictures play out from
overseas we've seen anti-war protesters
rounded up and arrested in moscow and
elsewhere throughout russia we've seen
awful pictures coming from from
throughout ukraine including one today
that was dramatic of a russian tank
literally rolling over ukrainian
civilian vehicle can you just give us a
sense is the president watching this
happen his reaction to this his message
to those anti-war protesters well i mean
it's they're it's horrific to watch it's
heart-wrenching to watch and we've all
seen the images uh the president the
vice president members of our national
security team and it almost doesn't
matter how much you've been through how
many conflicts you've watched over time
and he has unfortunately watched many in
a variety of national security roles
to feel heartbroken by what you're
seeing and happen in ukraine in a
sovereign country
that is as having its right to exist
threatened by russia the aggressor in
this case uh you know i would say our
message to the ukrainian people uh
continues to be that we stand with you
we support you we are going to do
everything humanitarian assistance
economic assistance continue to provide
security assistance and rally the world
to condemn the actions of president
putin and anti-war protesters in russia
well first i think we would say that uh
we are we are amazed by your courage um
your remarkable courage and standing up
against
what president putin is doing uh it is
uh not easy uh to protest in in many
scenarios but it's certainly not easy to
protest against the actions of an
autocratic leader and that's exactly
what uh these protesters are doing
there's a large room i'll ask only one
last question which is is a relative
supreme court blowing up on the
questions here the president wanted to
be a bipartisan process his members many
republicans chuck grassley the top
republican on the senate judiciary
committee three republicans helped
confirm judge katanji brown jackson
in the spring of last year one of them
lindsey graham today said among other
things
that this selection means the radical
left is one president biden over yet
again the white house's response well i
think what's most important for
everybody to unknow and understand is
more about judge jackson's record and
what was very compelling to and to go
back to wija's question sorry i didn't
answer this part
what was compelling to the president i
talked to him about with him about this
this morning and you heard him lay this
out in great detail in his remarks you
know judge jackson is someone who
very much is in the mold of justice
breyer having even clerked for him she
talked about that during his remarks
when she was confirmed as a district
judge in 2013 judge breyer praised her
for being a
wise decision and swore her in and even
parts of their biography overlapped time
on the sentencing commission time is a
federal judge but it's also how she has
approached her role as a judge that was
very compelling to the president she's
issued opinions without regard to
partisan considerations she's ruled in
favor of republicans and democrats she's
ruled for and against the government
regardless of whether the government is
led by a democratic president or a
republican president litigants lawyers
and judges across the ideological
spectrum appreciate her ability to be an
impartial adjudicator and that's exactly
what you want as a judge she's even
clerked for three different federal
judges i apologize for the interruption
i'm being notified that right now the
attacks in kiev are ramping up and that
air raid sirens are going off let's
listen
[Music]
that sounds just like the 11 pm church
bells
[Music]
okay we're going to continue monitoring
but there are reports that attacks are
starting now bombings are starting now
we will watch it processing
for ukrainians that do want to come to
the us as they did with afghans that
want to come to the u.s well it's a
slightly different circumstance i will
say because our assessment is that the
majority of refugees will want to go to
neighboring countries in europe many of
which have already conveyed publicly
that they will expect i guess from this
feed these are the sirens from from a
moment ago
okay
[Music]
okay that was two minutes ago so we're
gonna watch that very closely in
countries who are willing to welcome
these refugees uh you know have our
support in that effort go ahead thanks
jen um i know the white house has said
it won't be sending the us won't be
sending troops into ukraine to rescue
americans who are still there so what is
the us doing about americans who are
still left in ukraine as the situation
gets more dire well we i i will first
start by saying that we have been
warning for months now about the dire
circumstances developing in ukraine and
conveying very directly to american
citizens they should leave we have also
been in touch from the state department
with every american we can reach i would
point you to them for more specifics on
that and we continue to have the
capacity to
you know help them in a range of ways
even as we don't have a diplomatic uh
presence in ukraine in this i mean we
don't have people in the country right
now obviously but they are in
neighboring countries i would really
point you to the state department for
any more specifics the president is
obviously now going to be in delaware
this weekend can you share what he will
be doing there will he be traveling with
members of his national security team
will he be receiving regular updates on
ukraine sure he will have a meeting with
members of his national security team
tomorrow in delaware i will note that
well every president can work from
anywhere they are because that is how
presidencies are equipped he is
traveling to delaware for the memorial
service of a family member
and he will be
that is why he's traveling there this
weekend
go ahead just to follow my question does
the president have special secure
facilities in in wilmington we know that
obviously at camp david that is
something available um given the the
national security crisis is defining
that is also available the president has
the capacity to make a secure call from
anywhere he is yes and then on on the
supreme court how important is it to the
president that um
the
judge jackson receives bipartisan uh
support if she is confirmed and how much
political capital and time and energy is
he personally going to put in
to
getting republican support nominations
well i think tyler let me flip this
around a little bit for you and just say
the president's view is that when you
look at somebody like judge jackson who
has ex is extraordinarily qualified has
impeccable credentials
she has been allotted by a former
speaker of the house paul ryan who said
on her behalf
last when she was put forward last year
i know she's clearly qualified but it
bears repeating just how qualified she
is our politics may differ but my praise
for contagi's intellect for her
character for her intellect is
unequivocal
that she is somebody who has and i would
also note that former d.c district judge
thomas griffith appointed by president
george w bush publicly supported her d.c
court nomination and she received a
bipartisan letter of support from
individuals who co-clerked along judge
jackson so i think the bar here should
not be
what is the president going to do of
course he's going to engage with
democrats and republicans you've seen
him operate in that way to date it is
what are republicans going to do that's
a perfect answer it's like listen
we would much prefer
that republicans recognize her
qualifications and not obstruct for
political reasons that being said this
is an eminently qualified candidate and
the important thing is that since she's
qualified she end up on the court
because she's my choice whether
republicans want to
accept that or not
how much is that speech being
changed by
the russia ukraine crisis can you just
give us a little bit of a preview about
what we may hear from the president on
tuesday i certainly understand the
question but i can't give you a preview
of a speech four days from now uh quite
yet about and how it will address in a
developing conflict
but yeah uh president biden stated from
the outset you've reiterated that
reiterated today that he won't send us
troops to ukraine to fight russians
given the high stakes uh you know
president biden yesterday said uh russia
has aspirations beyond ukraine why isn't
this a fight worth sending us troops for
why and you're
in
why has the president assessed that
shouldn't be an option well i would say
first it's important to note that we
have
certainly
made clear not just by words but by
actions that we are going to continue to
support and even plus up our support for
nato defense operations and there was an
announcement yesterday of an increase of
additional 7 000 troops and obviously
there was a significant announcement
made today by nato uh we are uh firm we
will firmly stand behind our article uh
five obligations but i would say as it
relates to sending us troops into
ukraine uh the president the role of the
president of the united states any
president is to make an assessment about
what is in the interest of the united
states our national security interests
the american people and certainly weigh
very heavily uh how we're leading the
global community but it is not in our
interest to be in a war with russia and
so no we are not sending us troops to
ukraine well by stating up front uh that
this is not an option didn't president
biden take away what could have been a
threat to deter uh putin from invading
and to further uh uh push into ukraine
can you imagine the chaos if biden was
like no boots on the ground are a
possibility imagine what would be going
on right now pensions are on what his
intentions are not and that is his first
priority as president and finally what
was the white house's reaction to
president zolinski's today
in a video address saying that ukraine
has quote left alone to defend itself
against russia well as you know the
president spoke with president zielinski
and made clear to him during that
conversation that he and he commended
his brave uh leadership his brave
actions the brave actions of the
ukrainian people who were fighting to
defend their country he also conveyed uh
our ongoing economic humanitarian and
security support uh that we will
continue to provide so that is hardly
standing on the sidelines we are
providing again the largest provider of
security economic humanitarian
assistance of any country in the world
and we will continue to support
president zilenski and ukrainian people
the white house doesn't think he's been
left alone oh i think i'll leave it at
that go ahead uh thanks a lot jen does
the administration have any plans to
offer tps to ukrainians who are in the
united states or who might end up coming
to the united states does it support the
idea well there it's a process that
would be overseen by the interagency
through go through an interagency
process led by the department of
homeland security i know there are many
advocates for that but i don't have an
update on the process or if it will
happen
what plans uh does the administration in
regard to refugees sure what plans does
the administration have to take in uh
for the united states to take in some
refugees in the united states have there
been any planning discussions perhaps
with refugee groups uh to prepare this
do you have an anticipated number of how
many refugees may come to this i don't
have an updated and anticipated number
to project what i will convey to you is
that we are always in constant contact
with the refugee organizations who do
incredible work around the world but i
would also reiterate that what we've
seen happen over the last couple of days
as countries like poland germany and
others in europe make clear that they
are going they are opening their arms to
welcome refugees from ukraine those are
neighboring countries so we do
anticipate the vast majority will uh
want to go to countries in europe would
you anticipate that some would come to
the united we are open to that yes
and if i could ask one more senator
coons floated the idea of 10 billion a
10 billion dollar emergency supplemental
package just uh does the administration
support that proposal we are having
ongoing conversations uh with congress
about additional assistance to ukraine
our omb leadership is having those
conversations and so i will leave it to
them to put out any updated specific
number from our end but those are
underway go ahead
um why doesn't uh president biden want
to talk to vladimir putin right now
because he's invading a sovereign
country
isn't he going to be potentially
invading that for years
well i would say that a moment where a
leader is uh is a beginning and in the
middle of invading a sovereign country
is not the moment where uh diplomacy
feels appropriate
it does not mean we have ruled out
diplomacy forever obviously the
president remains open to engaging on at
a leader to leader level but this is not
the moment anything biden does is wrong
and anything biden doesn't do is wrong
with you know sanctions on everything
it doesn't seem what you know are you
guys waiting for to fall or sanctions on
everything how do you mean
all russian
you know all russian transactions and
oil and gas or like do do you think that
americans are not willing to that
doesn't know what he's asking
like if i hit at the gas pump
well i would say there's a couple of um
principles through which the president
has approached sanctions
one is maximizing the impact on uh
russian leadership and so are you guys
like sanctions on everything is cool or
like what so that there will be a
particular squeeze we've obviously taken
steps already that have gone far and
above what have ever been done what has
ever been done in the past if you look
at just 10 the 10 financial institutions
that we sanctioned uh they hold a huge
percentage of they're about 80 percent
of the russian banking sector that is a
significant step that was announced
yesterday the export controls step that
was announced yesterday means that they
will be
they won't have the ability to get
access to the technology that and and
semiconductors and ai that president
putin desperately wants to continue to
innovate his economy moving forward uh
there's also of course europeans are
also looking at european countries are
also looking at some of their reliance
on russia whether it's for energy or
other purposes and they're making their
own decisions about diversifying and as
i noted a little bit earlier the ruble
remains about 10 percent weaker
year-to-date and the worst performing
emerging market currency in the world so
what should be clear here is that there
are already huge impacts there is
already an enormous squeeze on the
russian uh financial system and economy
what we are also what the president is
also focused on as a principal is not is
taking steps making sure we are
minimizing the impact on the american
people on the global economic system and
we of course weigh that as we have a
responsibility to do and we want to
first and foremost i should have said
this first take these steps united with
our uh partners and allies in europe
does the um administration have any
message to american companies that do
business in russia with entities that
are not necessarily on the sanction list
would you like to see u.s citizens
not buy russian products would you like
to see us based ceos not look for
business in russia
we're not trying to
hurt the people of russia or the russian
people we're trying to squeeze the
financial system and sector to uh to
make sure there are significant
consequences for the actions of the
president go ahead thanks jen so
understanding there's no plans for
presidents uh biden and putin to speak
is there any line of communication
between the white house and the kremlin
right now
uh i i don't have additional details on
that at this point in time obviously our
national security team has a range of
means of communicating with the russians
we take what you said earlier in your
answer to mean that the president won't
speak with putin unless putin
de-escalates or withdraws well again
it's not the appropriate moment right
now i can't give you i'm not going to
give you a forever or never because
that's not how he feels but
they are actively invading
ukraine they are moving on the capitol
let me mention something that i see
people in the chat talking about which i
was not going to bring up there's a
hypothesis it's speculation that the
reason putin is doing this is that putin
is very very sick possibly terminally
ill
and the things that are often floated
are parkinson's or prostate cancer and a
bunch of doctors have looked at video of
putin and have said that there's really
no particular evidence that that's
what's going on so it's a completely
speculative thing and the idea would be
putin's been really coveted cautious
there's all these videos of him where
the tables are like 40 feet long where
he's 40 feet away from the person he's
meeting with and he doesn't look good it
looks like he might have filmed both of
the videos this week at the same time
because he was wearing the same suit in
the same position his makeup looked
identical that you know he may he may
not be
well and so he filmed them both at the
same time it's completely completely
speculative
it requires so many different things to
be true that are spec
is it impossible no it's not impossible
but
i think
you know we're trying to make sense out
of something that doesn't make sense
which is just like invading ukraine
based on how we interpret it and
it it's it's speculative and not
implausible but there's no evidence i'm
aware of energy sector
at some level on the table if putin gets
even more aggressive and also you know
there are also some other countries that
um are have worked for carved outs for
instance italy and luxury goods what is
the u.s view of those kinds of of
exceptions being made for things that
are maybe a lot less essential as much
as we might like them than oil and gas
speaking for yourself um
so i would say in the energy sector no
option is off the table but again to go
back to the principle some of the
principles here our sanctions are
designed to harm russia's economy not
our economy and that's a key balance
that we're clearly trying to strike and
i think when delete as delete has been
in here a few times over the last week
he's conveyed we do risk assessments
right and impact assessments um and
that's a part of it uh the other factor
here on the energy sector is that
starting out with energy or could
actually benefit president putin and pad
his pockets because given high oil and
gas prices cutting off russian oil and
gas could drive prices up to
putin's benefit so that's obviously a
factor as well but it's not off the
table but we look at a range of issues
in terms of how what what other
countries have fought in foreign but
they're not functioning did the
administration have a view of that
i don't think i think look our focus
right now is that um we are we are
working in close coordination and in
lockstep with our european counterparts
it does not mean everything is identical
it is not identical but what you have
seen across the board is very strong
impactful sanctions that the shared hope
is that they will have significant uh
economic and financial consequences
does the administration have an estimate
of how many russian deaths or casualties
there have been in ukraine
i don't have that assessment from here i
don't expect we would have that
assessment from here canadians have this
number 3800 that they've been putting
out for 2800 that they've been putting
out today
do you have any sense of the accuracy or
the order of magnitude i i don't have
any assessment from here and i don't
anticipate we would i know that so
ukrainians are claiming they killed
2 800 russians on ukrainian soil did i
under understand that correctly they
were able to make an assessment of
casualties uh earlier today one more
question on the supreme court process
um you you mentioned three uh accounting
interviewed in person
uh just wanna make sure those the only
three candidates he interviewed in
person do you interview any candidates
virtually those are the candidates he
interviewed okay yes okay thank you yeah
go ahead do you have another one no no
okay
go ahead thank you so much thank you
does the house stand by the support you
guys gave to brazil to become a global
partner and nato after president boson
aromath last week with president putin
and still president boss didn't condemn
the invasion
again as i said in relation to a
question a little bit earlier i mean our
uh view and our okay was it casualties
or killed right because casualties
includes injured and now i'm not now i'm
doubting whether they said casualties
are killed uh where where you want to be
in history as the history books look
back uh but that doesn't i don't have
anything in terms of our change of our
view of our overarching relationship go
ahead yeah can i just follow up on that
question in terms of building a global
coalition against russia right i mean
india for example a quad member it's the
only quad member that's not implementing
uh export controls for example i think
the president yesterday mentioned that
that issue still hasn't been resolved is
he planning to call call prime minister
modi i think prime minister modi called
president putin yesterday uh and just
can you speak more broadly in terms of
bringing all these other partners that
maybe you know not in europe but you
know the quad as well as perhaps asean
members were
pretty uh ambivalent and cautious about
condemning the russian innovation
i would say some were but i wouldn't say
the majority were um and we continue to
engage uh with the indians with other
asean partners on both what we're seeing
on the ground uh
our our continued condemnation of the
actions of president putin
in ukraine and we will continue to
uh push others to follow suit and just
to follow up uh delta announced today
that they're suspending code sharing
with aeroflot yes did the white house
have anything to do with the decision
and are you urging other american
companies to uh urge them to be the same
that's a decision by a private sector
company so i don't have any more
comments on the state of the union okay
preview a little bit on the foreign
policy we already said now
the union i mean obviously with the
prices in ukraine i know that you you're
not going to be able to preview that but
just in general now with ukraine before
that with the afghanistan withdrawal
what can the president say to show that
his foreign policy doctrine is
succeeding
well
without previewing the state of the
union which we'll do later this evening
or later this weekend sorry it's kind of
all one day that's running together um
we will do later this weekend i expect
so look at look ahead to that or we'll
have more to say later this weekend you
know it's also as it relates to russia
ukraine you know we are unfortunately
still in the middle of this conflict
right we are in the middle of an active
invasion so i just can't give you a
preview of what that will look like in
the state of the union um as it relates
to
how the president views his approach to
foreign policy
you know the president has
ran for president wanting to return
america's seat at the world wanting to
return
to a time where other leaders around the
world could trust the word and the
commitments of the united states and
what you have seen over the last few
months is the president deliver on
exactly that he has been leading the
effort in the world to stand up to
russia stand up to the efforts the
aggression uh the invasion of a
sovereign country um well i'm not going
to get into the specifics of of what is
going to be in the state of the union
that's exactly what he said he would do
when he was running go ahead
the president said he's doing everything
he can to bring down um energy prices
yes prices here in the us
is on the table then or is he
considering reversing some of the
policies and regulations that they put
into place that constricts the long-term
supply of it to let europe be more
reliant on the u.s for oil and natural
gas you mean like lng exports or
something like that but also oil prices
allowing you know opening up drilling
again
reversing the ban on leases
on federal lands well well i think
what's important to note here and i
talked about this a little bit yesterday
is that
there are a range of available oil
leasing sites that oil companies are not
utilizing so you should ask them about
that you know the president's view on on
reducing our dependence on foreign oil
and actually his view is that this makes
that case even stronger and diversifying
the range of means of energy production
everywhere around the world
as it relates to lng exports i don't
have anything new on that our focus
right now is on working with
or engaging with a range of countries i
mentioned japan yesterday having
conversations with others who may have
the availability of supply natural gas
supply that was coming from the united
states to provide to europe in this time
where they need it and we're seeing some
encouraging developments on that front
um opec is making moves now to get ready
to include iranian oil um and if the us
is successful with the iran nuclear deal
would the president then welcome iranian
oil coming into the u.s to lower gas
prices well again uh we're not quite at
the point of a final deal uh on uh the
nuclear deal so we will talk about that
if we get to that point let's see what
thanks you've talked a couple times
about the us engaging in diplomacy with
russia going forward when he announced
the sanctions today against putin and
lavrov the british prime minister told
nato leader that there could be no
normalization with russia after the
attack on ukraine does this
administration share that view well
again in this moment
the i've conveyed pretty clearly the
president has no intentions at this
moment to engage with president putin
right he was just sanctioned we just
made a decision in coordination in close
lockstep with the europeans to sanction
him a head of state that is a very rare
step to take and obviously we've issued
significant sanctions that cover 80
percent of the financial sector so no
we're not in a business as usual moment
at this point in time and obviously
de-escalation would help return us to a
state where that could proceed does the
white house right now believe that
president zielinski is safe in keith we
are in close touch with him well i'm not
going to give you updates on his
security
state we
certainly the president just spoke with
him earlier today and he continues to be
the president of ukraine
go ahead hi in regards to the uh new cdc
guidance on the pandemic which of course
will then be the you know
the new fight administration guidance
what is the
what will the message be to americans in
regards to these new metrics and this
the new guidance as to where we are
independent already been asked well i
would say um
if you look at the specific of them
where we are moving the president we've
talked a little bit about how we want to
move to a time and a place where we are
uh uh you know i do want to let you guys
know there are reports from the last 15
minutes that there are discussions
between russia and ukraine
about
meeting for negotiations that's the
latest
process um and we're moving forward in
that process
as a result of these uh this
announcement today and these updated
recommendations today more than half the
country 70 percent of americans live in
areas where the cdc no longer recommends
universal masking obviously if people
want to wear a mask because they're
immunocompromised because uh they have
concerns about their safeties and their
safety in their communities they have
the ability to do that absolutely that
is certainly a step forward so um you
know that this is part of that process
and i expect we'll have more to say soon
is there concern that this might
imply or
have have folks think that then
therefore the pandemic is over and can
issue
all caution and then secondly are kind
of added on to that um are you confident
that there will be an ability to reverse
course if things get bad again well
if if nobody is saying it's uh means
it's over including anybody who has a
big platform for example then that we're
not concerned about that that is not
what we're conveying from here right
what we are conveying from here and what
the cdc is conveying is that
america is in a stronger place today
as a nation we have more tools ever than
ever before to protect ourselves from
covet 19 vaccination boosters treatments
testing high quality masks improved
ventilation over 200 million people are
vaccinated nearly 100 million americans
have been boosted and the cdc is
providing public health guidance that
has a couple of different clear levels
so that people can understand what their
recommendation is as it relates to
wearing a mask that's exactly what this
is there are still people dying every
day of covid there are still
immunocompromised populations
but what we are trying to work towards
is a period of time where we are where
covet is not disrupting our daily lives
uh go ahead i just wanted to know uh you
said that the president has done
everything in his power we've seen the
sanctions shoring up the nato eastern
flank all of that but no troops you re
repeated that
doesn't that also send the message to
vladimir putin clearly it hasn't stopped
him that other nations in the region
that are not nato members are also free
game for him since
he's not going to have that stock well i
don't think the crippling sanctions that
the president has issued or approved and
we announced yesterday that cover 80
percent of the finance it's quite
literally a no win because if biden
leaves open the possibility of troops
then he gets called a war bloodthirsty
warmonger who wants to get us into an on
the ground conflict and if he says we're
not gonna do that then they say should
you really be drawing that line because
then you're just telling putin no matter
what you do we won't send troops now the
truth is
you can still be involved
without sending troops in so many
different ways including
without advocating for any of these
things the cyber attack possibilities
you know all these different it it's
it's you
either way they would be critical of
biden for that objective is to divide uh
the west um it's having the opposite
effect so uh i i don't think that would
be our assessment
go ahead can i just uh just a quick
question on cyber attacks yeah the nato
secretary general again said that
he would view a cyber attack on a nato
member this time talking about nato
members as
something that would
be under article five is that the view
of the united states also that is cyber
yeah i answered this yesterday and i
said that it would be up to nato members
uh to determine what that looks like and
what any response would look like go
ahead
the decision today uh with congressman
clyburn he of course was a big booster
yeah he called him this morning
thanks jeff okay one more one more last
one thank you oh go ahead yeah thank you
jen
you've said you've said that the u.s
will not go to war against russia
obviously russia is heavily harmed the
u.s is ugly um and i'm i'm just
wondering if you're not being pragmatic
here in russia
have you not been pragmatic to recognize
that he may not be in the interest of
the us
for ukraine to be a member of nato which
is the key
request from russia
i'm not sure i'm understanding your
question is it are you asking me if in
the interest of the us for ukraine he
never understands this guy's question it
is up to every country to determine what
alliances they want to join or not join
and that is not a pressure point we
issue from the united states and we
think it's important for that to remain
open
for a job at cnn or msnbc
uh i have uh more than enough on my
plate here and so you can't get rid of
me quite yet sorry peter for you on that
so i will see you all on monday right
thank you everyone
oh man if you guys didn't hear the
question there's these rumors floating
around that she's it's not the rumor is
cnn and msnbc would like to have her
not that she's looking for a job all
right let's go to nigel farage for the
toxic coda to the evening
saying that taiwan is part of china
if china takes taiwan you realize what
that will do us
despite them as in investments
the semiconductors that are needed
for so much of our modern life
the semiconductors that are needed
without wind looking very strongly would
grind to a halt
they are still
manufactured for the most part in taiwan
if
china moves
against the weak west
if china moves
against the weak
american president
if you're looking for colloidal silver
or essential oils and you think there's
10 people you might be able to recruit
into your downline
nigel farage has a presentation for you
defenses for all of us
so you see however you feel sitting here
right now
however uncomfortable you feel about
this burden of responsibility that is on
america's shoulders you can see if we
don't act
don't get this right it will have
catastrophic consequences
they're the enemies that we face
died but we also face enemies inside
our universities
have been turned
into madrassas of marxism
determined to indoctrinate and poison
our young people he's out of his mind
is that better
no we can still hear you
would have thought cpac could have got
the kit right but anyway
our young people are being poisoned
we're being turned against ourselves
what's these great threats listen guys
education is bad
uh elementary schools very bad high
schools terrible
college liberal indoctrination doctors
can't trust them
media is bad
news stations bad
hollywood bad
books bad you've better just sit there
in a dark room with a candle and a bible
or otherwise it's going to be very bad
to an organization called black lives
matter and nobody seems
very few people have got the courage
to stand up and to fight that so we have
that problem within
that we have to fight and i know many of
you are doing it you're running for
school boards you're getting involved to
tweet about that but if we're going to
make the world a better place
if we're going to keep our history our
heritage our culture
if we're going to defend western
civilization
this
is the battleground it's america
because if america falls
the whole of the free world will fall
you've got to win this fight and to do
that
to do that
you've got to take back the house
you've got to take back the senate
you've got to take back in 2024 the
presidency of the usa
and you can do it
you can do it the democrats aren't
making it let's see you can do it
you can do it the democrats are making a
complete mess of everything
but don't underestimate their machine
don't underestimate their discipline
don't underestimate how well-funded they
are
and to beat them they're not that
well-funded
is the silent majority
to stand up and say i am going to do
something i am going to make an effort i
am going to join an organization
we need you all of us in the free world
need you to win this
and i want to leave you with one last
thought strike and strike and strike
november the 3rd
2020
the events of that day
or should i say the events of the
preceding weeks
it's called election day
but when you have mass mail out ballots
the election day takes place weeks
before
there is no
form
of mail postal voting
that is not open to fraud abuse and
intimidation
never anywhere
and i've seen it
i've seen it in britain's cities tony
blair introduced this it's been a
disaster
america it's trump with a british accent
and slightly better education it makes
sense
for the republican party
to go on talking
about the stolen election
well you may say yes in this hall
because you're political activists and
you understand what happened
remember most voters
are busy with their lives
busy with their mortgages
busy with their kids
worried about their jobs worried about
the price of gas the cost of living in
all of those things
and this message of a stolen election
if you think about it
is actually a negative backward-looking
message he's right there is a better
there is a better but more positive
message very light applause he needs to
embrace and it's this
we are going
state by state vote by vote to make sure
that america
has the best the cleanest the fairest
election system anywhere in the western
world
we will make sure no election again ever
can be open to doubt
and that negative anger must be turned
into a positive you've got to offer the
voters of this country a shining city on
the hill you've got to give them a
vision people want dreams people want
hopes
and the deliverers of that message
are you guys
you are the people's army you are the
ones that can inspire you are the ones
that can mobilize you are the ones that
can motivate
the only question is
are you ready for this great battle
are you ready for america to once again
take on its position as the leader of
the free world
are you ready for a big win in the
midterms in november
thank you seapan
[Music]
right
[Music]
okay that is the conclusion i think of
cpac for today nigel farage now they're
moving on to a job fair in the room
panza cola h1 that's the next thing on
the agenda all right everybody we are
into hour for and that will conclude our
coverage today i want every last one of
you come on tomorrow to join me here
come on david right at 6 00 pm eastern
time
for the keynote of cpac with donald
trump
and then tuesday for the state of the
union address with president joe biden i
want every one of you here i really do
okay um see everybody then thank you for
joining me
you